[Musik]
wir sind menschen aus der mitte der
gesellschaft
menschen mit unterschiedlichsten
persönlichkeiten und qualifikationen
doch so unterschiedlich wie auch sind
haben wir doch das gleiche
gemeinsam für österreich
[Musik]
was man kameraden nicht verbindet ist
der wille zu helfen so zählt zu unseren
vielfältigen aufgaben die unterstützung
beim katastrophenschutz hier wird das
wissen jedes einzelnen eingebracht ob
bei der beseitigung von unwetterschäden
oder bei hochwasser wir sind jederzeit
zur stelle
genauso wenn es um die sicherung unserer
außengrenzen gilt seit jahrzehnten
leistet die miliz bei
sicherheitspolizeilichen assistenz
einsetzen einen unverzichtbaren beitrag
[Musik]
vor allem gegen die aber auch regelmäßig
für den militärischen ernstfall denn die
miliz ist ein elementarer bestandteil
der militärischen landesverteidigung
[Musik]
zur landesverteidigung zählt dabei auch
dass sich ein lebensnotwendiger
infrastruktur im einsatzfall betrifft
das zum beispiel die strom und
wasserversorgung
[Musik]
dir das jägerbataillon steiermark
erzherzog johann sind stets bereit für
dich und für unser österreich
[Musik]
sehr geehrte zuseherinnen und zuseher
wer die kameraden wir dürfen sie recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zu unserer
sendung anlässlich des tages der miliz
2022 es führen sie durch die sendung
ja johannesburger und major klaus
stockinger wir senden heute hier live
aus dem festsaal des bundesministeriums
für landesverteidigung und bei uns zu
gast sind viele verdiente kameraden und
wir danken an dieser stelle sehr
herzlich für ihr erscheinen der tag der
miliz ist auch gleichzeitig der tag der
uniform und wir hoffen dass auch sie
außerdem gerade heute in der
öffentlichkeit stolze träger unsere
uniform präsentieren und damit deutlich
unterstreichen dass sie teil des
österreichischen bundesheeres sind und
damit teil unserer großen grünen familie
denn wir sind ein bundesheer
lassen sie uns gleich zu beginn danke
sagen als wehrpflichtige des
mittelstandes sind sie da aktive teil
der einsatzorganisation und leisten seit
jahrzehnten freiwillige
unterstützungsleistungen als soldaten
für die aufrechterhaltung des friedens
betriebszustände rund 50 prozent des
personals in den innen und
auslandseinsätzen und unterstützen
laufend den dienstbetrieb als ausbildner
als lehrpersonal oder als vertretungen
für kameraden kameras dienst an dass die
sich in aus und weiterbildung die sich
in karenz oder auf urlaub befinden sie
unterstreichen damit eindrucksvoll dass
wenn die miliz gebraucht wird dann sind
wir da das ist für uns nicht
verhandelbar und lassen sie mich gleich
zu beginn innehalten und dankeschön
sagen danke an alle wehrpflichtigen des
mittelstandes für ihren unschätzbaren
beitrag für die sicherheit und die
stabilität in unserer heimat dankeschön
wir haben für sie heute ein
ambitioniertes und interessantes
programm erstellt wir beginnen mit den
grußworten unserer frau bundesministerin
setzen fort mit den grußworten
stellvertretend für den chef des
generalstabs general maria hofbauer
einen ausblick auf die aktuelle
situation und die zukunft der medien
durch unsere mädels beauftragten general
damals jeder es folgt ein vortrag über
die kriegerischen konflikt in der
ukraine vor und generalmajor hofbauer
und wir enden die heutige veranstaltung
mit einer mit einer kleinen talkrunde
mit den interessensvertretern der
österreichischen gesellschaft der
österreichischen offiziersgesellschaft
der österreichischen
offiziersgesellschaft und des mediziners
österreich ja es geht los wir erwarten
die grußworte unserer verbundes minister
frau magister klaudia tanner
geschätzte milizsoldaten und
milizsoldaten so viele einsätze des
bundesheeres wären ohne sie nicht
möglich sie ermöglichen es in in und
auslands einsätzen besten möglich im
sinne der auftrags erfüllung und im
vollen personellen umfang
sicherzustellen
ich glaube das beste beispiel dafür
das war die erste teil mobilmachung der
miliz am vierten mai 2020 also die
pandemie überrollte das 1400
medizinerinnen und soldaten sie waren
als die 13-jährige kompanien eingerückt
sind um den coupe 19 einsatz in ganz
österreich zu unterstützen dadurch ist
bewiesen worden dass sie ein
verlässlicher garant für die
durchhaltefähigkeit des bundesheeres
sind der auftrag fordert aber auch mit
investitionen in das milizsystem die
sind unabdingbar mit dem 200 millionen
euro - paket konnten wir bereits die
ersten die dringendsten beschaffungen
durchführen die investitionen im
mobilität in bewaffnung und ausrüstung
die bringen eine deutliche steigerung
der materiellen einsatzfähigkeit mit
sich die umsetzung all dieser maßnahmen
ist bis 20 24 vorgesehen durch diese
investitionen stellen wir sicher dass
ihre verbände und einheiten zukünftig
zur auftragserfüllung bestmöglich
ausgestattet sind damit sie bei krisen
und katastrophen noch rascher und
effizienter helfen können und weil sie
es sich auch verdient haben weil das
notwendig ist zur erfüllung der einsätze
man darf aber auch vor allem eines nicht
vergessen sie leisten ja nicht nur als
bürgerinnen und bürger in uniform einen
unglaublich wichtigen beitrag zur
sicherheit österreichs sondern auch in
ihren unternehmen daher will ich an
dieser stelle auch den arbeitgeberinnen
und arbeitgebern mein herzliches
dankeschön aussprechen ohne die gute
zusammenarbeit ohne die kooperation mit
den unternehmen würde unser bundesheer
nicht in so bewährter weise
funktionieren somit kann ich festhalten
dass wir gemeinsam einen wesentlichen
beitrag zur umfassenden
landesverteidigung leisten in den
letzten jahren ist in sachen miliz
einiges geschehen der einsatz der miliz
hat sich gelohnt und sie als mit
soldatinnen und soldaten
sie sind auch mir ein sehr persönliches
anliegen ich möchte daher ihren heutigen
festtag den tag der miliz nutzen und
mich bei jedem bei jedem einzelnen ganz
herzlich für das erbrachte engagement
bedanken wir wissen ihre leistungen zu
schätzen wir sind stolz auf unsere
soldaten und soldaten und ich darf ihnen
abschließend ihnen und ihren familien
weiterhin viel gesundheit wünschen
soldatenglück und ich freue mich auch in
zukunft auf ihre leistungen für unsere
menschen für unsere heimat für unser
österreich es lebe das österreichische
bundesheer es lebe die republik
österreich
das in ihren worten gesagt die miliz ist
für das österreichische bundesheer für
unsere republik unverzichtbar es gilt
jetzt die personelle und materielle
einsatzbereitschaft wieder herzustellen
und alle arbeiten daran wir dürfen jetzt
begrüßen bei uns generalmajor hofbauer
der stellvertretend für den chef des
generalstabes seine grußworte an die
miliz richten wird
keiner mehr über die charaktere war vor
allem sieben kameraden
ich darf im namen des ex
generalstabschef scanner stedinger recht
herzlich sie hier zu dieser
veranstaltung begrüßen und möchte ein
paar worte an sie richten die mir
besonders am herzen liegen
nicht nur die
vorkommnisse in der ukraine in den
letzten monaten die wir beobachten
sondern auch bereits davor war für uns
im bundesheer hier auch in der planung
im ministerium ganz klar dass für die
einsatzbereitschaft des bundesheeres die
miliz die voraussetzung da ist und ich
möchte auch ganz klar stellen dass er
sich hier ein bundesheer und dort ein
mediziner gibt sondern dass wir alle nur
gemeinsam funktionieren können und je
näher die krisen rücken und desto
schwieriger situation wird und davon
können wir ausgehen dass das in
absehbarer zeit nicht unbedingt besser
wird desto stärker müssen wir auf diesen
aspekt uns ausrichten das bundesheer
steht am anfang einer
grundsätzlichen trendwende einer in
bewegung zur umsetzung der streitkräfte
profils unser heer des tv
bundesministerin angeordnet hat zur
umsetzung dass eine klare hinwendung zur
militärischen landesverteidigung in
österreich nach sich zieht und somit
sich nicht mehr die frage der ausrüstung
und des einsatzes von ausgewählten
teilen des bundesheeres unterstützt
durch die miliz stellt sondern sich die
frage stellt wie das mobil gemacht die
bundesheer oder das teil gemacht teil
mobil gemacht
in den einsatz geht und so möchte ich
ganz klar feststellen dass wir das
bundesheer so betrachten als ob es mobil
gemacht wird mit all den
herausforderungen die sich hier
auftun mit allen herausforderungen die
wir hier finanzieller aber auch im
denken
hier aufnehmen müssen das heißt die
miliz ist insgesamt zu denken nicht hier
die selbstständig suggerierte und hier
die miliz anteile in den kleinen
verbänden und hier die präsenten
verbände sondern das bundesheer muss als
gesamtheit funktionieren sonst wird es
nämlich nicht seine einsätze zur
militärischen landesverteidigung und die
steht im vordergrund und wird immer
wichtiger werden sonst wird es diese
aufträge nicht dafür können die
bedrohungen sind vielfältig
das umfeld wird aggressiver der druck
auf die peripherie ist gewachsen und wir
dürfen nicht nur die ukraine sehen
sondern sollten auch die konflikte im
nahen und mittleren osten sind die
auswirkungen
dessen was die klimawandel nach sich
zieht die auswirkungen dessen was unter
umständen die folgen der ukraine auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent sind das sind
fragen mit denen wir uns unverzüglich
auseinander setzen müssen um die sich
auch auf das militär aus wirkt aber eben
nicht nur weil das militär im in
österreich wo sich in eine umfassende
landesverteidigung einbetten und auch
hier gibt es viel zu tun die umfassende
landesverteidigung ist zu modernisieren
und entsprechend auf das
einundzwanzigste jahrhundert auf
vordermann zu bringen und dort gehört
die geistige landesverteidigung dabei
dazu die wirtschaftliche und natürlich
die militärische auch aus einem teil
davon aber eben nicht nur
aus meiner sicht ist dieser heutige tag
auch wenn wir in virtuell durchführen
müssen ganz wesentlicher um auch mal
neueste informationen an sie weitergeben
zu können
darauf freue ich mich auf die worte des
miliz beauftragt johannes eder und darf
auch dann selbst ein paar kurze worte
zur ukraine und vor allem auf die
auswirkungen auf das österreichische
bundesheer
legen die herausforderungen vor der wir
stehen sind umfassend ich gebe auch zu
dass auch diese hier im generalstab noch
nicht endgültig abgeschlossen sind aber
wir haben eine solide basis wir wissen
grundsätzlich weil wir ja das
milizsystem einmal aufgebaut haben
gemeinsam wie es geht wenn es
funktionieren soll das heißt wir können
durchaus ein bisschen auch in die bücher
gehen und schauen wie hat denn das
früher funktioniert und gewisse dinge
herausholen und modernisieren zeitgemäß
anpassen aber entsprechend wieder
beleben und sie können sich sicher sein
dass wir das auch tun viel arbeit liegt
vor uns in diesem sinne noch herzliche
grüße von generalmajor stedinger und ich
darf das wort wieder an die moderation
zurückgehen
[Musik]
milizsoldaten lernen führen und sie
lernt dass er verdammt hohen niveau und
es wird immer wieder unterschätzt eine
offiziersausbildung oder unter fischers
ausbildung ist geprägt von den ganz
klassischen selben inhalten wie führungs
seminare immer sie in der
privatwirtschaft gezahlt bekommen den
unterschied habe ich nicht gemerkt für
mich von den inhalten her nur dass beim
bundesheer ist noch intensiv auch noch
weiter geht nämlich bis in
extremsituationen und das glaube ich ist
ein absoluter mehrwert der unbezahlbar
die jeder mit zur tat kann für die
sicherheit der republik österreich und
damit automatisch für die sicherheit
eines unternehmens unglaublich viel
einbringen lilith soldatinnen und
soldaten leisten einen wichtigen beitrag
zur sicherheit österreichs in uniform
aber auch in ihren unternehmen
gegenseitige anrechnung militärischer
und ziviler ausbildungen
akzeptanz der miliz tätigkeit in
unternehmen die tüv austria leed
zertifizierung
[Musik]
ja vom nebeneinander zum miteinander das
ist das entscheidende
die entscheidende botschaft die wir
heute setzen wollen wir sind eben ein
österreichisches bundesheer und das
besteht aus dem dienst ahnt es besteht
aus dem
bestand und es steht aus dem reserve
stand wir sind rund
1,1 millionen österreicherinnen und
österreicher die hier ihren
grundwehrdienst geleistet haben und hier
einen wesentlichen beitrag gemeinsam zur
sicherheits- und zur stabilität
beitragen wollen ja wir sind jetzt auch
personen seit 20 jahren begeisterte
milizsoldaten haben wir organisch
aufgewachsen als stellvertretender
gruppen kommentare bis heute
stellvertretender bataillonskommandant
in der personalreserve und haben heute
bei uns einen kameraden dem ich den ja
johannes becker der selbst in einer
krisenhaften situation in der sich
österreich aktuell auch noch befindet
nämlich angesichts der kurve 19 pandemie
hier 2020 im einsatz war und vielleicht
könntest du dazu einige erfahrungswerte
teilen ja dem war tatsächlich so war
damals mit meiner zweiten jeder kompanie
von tirol im einsatz du hast ja schon
angesprochen vom nebeneinander zum
miteinander das ist glaube dass
entscheidenden gewesen bei diesem
einsatz wo wirklich der präsenz stadt
und der miliz stand sehr nahe aneinander
heran gerückt sind
was waren die herausforderungen bei
diesem einsatz wir haben natürlich auch
sogenannte befristet beorderte bei uns
dabei gehabt das sind herr milizsoldaten
wehrpflichtige des berufsstandes die
keine übungs verpflichtung haben und
hier das erste mal bei uns mit dabei
waren und quasi nur die
einsatzvorbereitung mitgemacht haben es
war eine wesentliche herausforderung und
auch die ableitung für uns es ist
wichtig dass die kameraden bei den
übungen dabei sehen und deshalb müssen
wir schauen dass wir so viel als möglich
unbefristet beorderte zur miliz bekommen
vielleicht erklären wir das an dieser
stelle ist in der bevölkerung und in der
öffentlichkeit bekannt der ausdruck mit
soldaten ganz richtig ist das nicht denn
soldaten sind all jene die ihr einen
eine wert dienstleistung oder eine
präsenz dienstleistung erfüllt sind wir
so alle soldaten und wenn diese wert
dienstleistung hier ändert dann geht man
wieder zurück in den match stand und
geht dort dann in wahrheit seinem
hauptberuf nämlich privat
wirtschaftlicher natur nach und
organisiert dort seine tätigkeiten ja
vielleicht die zahlen wir haben aktuell
im mittelstand rund 120000
österreicherinnen und österreicher davon
sind rund
36.000 mit einer forderung und in diesen
beorderten jetzt wird es ein bisschen
kompliziert aber es ist wichtig sind
16.000 ohne übungs verpflichtung und
20.000 aktuell mit übungs verpflichtung
und die wollen wir uns wenden denn das
sind die aktiven mit soldaten die hier
eben den dienst an unterstützen aber
immer auch in den in- und auslands
einsatz sehr fleißig wir gehen ja wir
haben heute bei uns unseren mädels
befragten generalmajor hannes eder der
seit mehreren jahrzehnten von einer ganz
wesentlichen leistung spricht nämlich
von der personellen und materiellen
einsatzbereitschaft des österreichischen
bundesheeres und wir werden jetzt hören
was in den letzten jahren geleistet
wurde und was der plan für die zukunft
vielen dank sehr geehrter herr
generalmajor sehr geehrte
kreative kameraden ich freue mich dass
ich heute wieder hier sein kann heute
ein insofern auch wieder interessanter
tag für mich den in der früh rot mit
uniform und die besprechung teilnehmer
wurden also sehr verwundert wie sie
gekommen sind es wurden teilnehmer
höchstrangige teilnehmer aus der
österreichischen medien wirtschaft wo
wir über das thema bewegtbild und welche
entwicklungen des digital gibt
gesprochen haben und ich war mit uniform
dort und habe ihnen erklärt warum das so
ist also ganz interessant und ich komme
unmittelbar in unserem haus findet
gerade statt der tag der weiterbildung
also wir haben den tag der miliz den tag
der weiterbildung und in unserem haus
sind
wirklich sehr viele it-verantwortliche
aus ganz österreich aus den
verschiedensten unternehmungen die sich
mit dem thema weiterbildung beschäftigen
und dankenswerterweise habe ich dort
auch den konkurrenten getroffen den
kombattanten abc abwehr zentrum
wo er wo man auch sieht dass es eine
vernetzung gibt auch beim thema bildung
und das finde ich wirklich toll und so
gesehen freue ich mich wenn ich jetzt
hier sein kann und auch einen
zwischenbericht geben darf was sich so
alles mittlerweile getan hat denn eines
ist ja auch ja normalerweise würde der
tag der miliz am nächsten samstag im
zuge des festaktes stattfinden aber
dieses jahr wird der festakt zum tag der
militäraktion ahl feiertag sein und ist
einer der höhepunkte der
informationsoffensive
miliz wo auch die frau bundesminister
dann die miliz award verleihen wird
beziehungsweise auch die auszeichnung
der besten miliz werber stattfinden wird
was ein sehr sehr würdiger rahmen und
auf den können wir uns alle schon jetzt
freuen ich bin der frau bundesminister
sehr sehr dankbar über die grußbotschaft
die sie uns gegeben hat weil sie ein
sehr persönliches bekenntnis wieder zur
miliz abgegeben hat und ich hatte in der
vorwoche wieder die möglichkeit bei der
frau bundesministerin einem termin
unsere unmittelbaren anliegen
vorzutragen auf die werde ich dann auch
noch kommen gleich auch das einerseits
durch corona andererseits aber auch
durch den angriffskrieg russlands auf
die ukraine mit sicherheit eine neue
phase in der sicherheitsarchitektur in
europa begonnen hat resident
ist eines der wesentlichen themen
geworden und ich kann ihnen sagen
gestern habe ich bei uns beim
sogenannten netzwerk banken treffen da
haben wir aus 15 ländern unsere
vorstände der raiffeisenbank
international zusammengezogen und da war
der vorstand der ukraine da und es war
auch unser vorstand aus russland an ich
kann ihnen sagen es ist bedrückend wenn
man dann unmittelbar spürt das war
gestern am abend das früher wo kleine
russland die allesamt gestanden sind ja
gruppen gebildet haben wo man jetzt
plötzlich spürt wie die auseinander
stehen sie sind zwar alle da und wenn
man sich dann die dinge anhört und der
seo und sem seo in russland die ungefähr
10.000 mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
verantwortet hat mal gesagt also wir
dürfen nicht glauben dass sie diesen
krieg mittragen sie müssen nur sehr
vorsichtig sein und er meint das
vielleicht von den 10.000 mag schon sein
dass vielleicht 100 oder 200 leute gibt
die diesen krieg befürworten aber der
rest mit sicherheit nicht ist eine hoch
interessante aussage und unsere leute
aus der ukraine wo die chief risk
officer eine dame ist die haut man im
detail geschildert wie sie das managen
und da kriegt man erst den unmittelbaren
eindruck was krieg einerseits bedeutet
und die wirtschaft aber bis zu einem
gewissen grad versucht wird am laufen zu
halten
und unter diesem eindruck stehe ich auch
heute noch und wo wir auch klarerweise
da eine sehr große bestätigung bekommen
insbesondere aus jenen ländern aus
rumänien slowakei bis hin zu holen die
sagen 'bitte bereitet sich vor wir
hätten nie geglaubt dass es zu so einer
situation kommen kann ich wollte das am
anfang meiner ausführungen stellen weil
das ist die realität in der wir uns
derzeit befinden und darum ist es auch
sehr wichtig dass wir heute mit uniform
unsere beruflichen themen auch
absolvieren um dieses bewusstsein noch
neu zusätzlich in der bevölkerung zu
verankern die sicherheit oder das krieg
nicht mehr in europa stattfindet
wissmann
es gehört mit sicherheit auch der
vergangenheit an und das ist eine tiefe
zäsur
es ist klar dass die
sicherheitsstrategie österreichs neu
bewertet wird oder neu zu bewerten sein
wird und politisch ist auch die
botschaft glaube ich angekommen dass
untätigkeit in sicherheitsfragen
hoffentlich auch der vergangenheit
angehören und
sicherheitsfragen müssen sehr aktiv und
dynamisch
abgehandelt werden und seinem handeln
führen
und klo es auch einerseits in der
bevölkerung sowieso vorhanden aber
oftmals auf der politischen ebene bis
hin ins parlament war das nach wie vor
nicht zu verankert wir müssen in unsere
sicherheit
investieren und ich bleibe da noch sehr
allgemein in die sicherheit investieren
weil das damit das österreichische
bundesheer massivst umfasst sein muss
das ist ja eine selbstverständlichkeit
was wir eben brauchen und der gibt's
einen durchaus spürbaren breiten
politischen konsens
investitionen in das österreichische
bundesheer in die ausrüstung in
militärische systeme das ist
unerlässlich und es wird wohl schon so
sein das wird hoffentlich bald auch
wirklich ein gemeingut in der
bevölkerung werden wenn es einen
entsprechenden ministerratsbeschluss und
dann im parlament auch ist dass wir ein
land das verteidigungsbudget brauchen
das richtung eineinhalb prozent sich
entwickeln muss wobei höhere sage ich
auch dass der staat in etwa mit einem
stattfinden wird und dann pro jahr dann
aufgedoppelt wird um 0,9 prozent für die
nächsten fünf jahre und da ist auch klar
und das habe ich auch immer wieder
transportiert das ist zusätzlich dann
zumindest am anfang gewisse sonder
investitionsbudgets geben sollte
schrägstrich müsste weil wie wir alle
wissen militärisches gerät ist nicht
durch schalter unteren verfügbar sondern
das hat alles entsprechende
vorlaufzeiten die finanzierung im
vorfeld sieger gestellt sein es hat die
neubelebung und daher general lotion
angesprochen der umfassenden
landesverteidigung und damit klarerweise
dass in den mittelpunkt stellen der
militärischen landesverteidigung
das ist es das politisch getragen werden
muss
und diese
forderung sei es normal ist hoffentlich
wirklich
parteiübergreifend bei allen politischen
verantwortungsträgern angekommen eine
weitere forderung die sich daraus ergibt
ist das thema verpflichtenden
milizübungen und dieses thema habe ich
in der vorwoche bei der frau
bundesminister angesprochen sie hat
jetzt einen auftrag einer prüfung
erteilt und in einer phase eins und zwei
werden wir schon sicherlich auch einen
schritt weiter wenn das gelänge aber das
ist rechtlich auch sehr komplexes feld
ist und wir haben uns umgehört
unsere befristet denn so wird was wir
brauchen sind unbefristete milizsoldaten
ja und da muss man schauen wie man wie
man zu diesem stand auch kommen wenn man
überlegen beziehungsweise der auftrag
ist erteilt diese prüfung zu machen denn
wir wissen auch nur wer übt wie auch die
möglichkeit hat in letzter konsequenz
mit vordruck bezügen der kann sich in
richtung wirklich militärische
landesverteidigung in der miliz auch
bewegen damit wird sein entsprechenden
kompetenz und qualität kommen nur so
können wir auch die personelle
einsatzbereitschaft in letzter
konsequenz
erreichen also die frau bundesminister
ist da sehr sehr sensibilisiert
und und wir sollten keine tagaus lassen
um diese forderung
weiterzutransportieren
verpflichtenden milizübungen und die
canucks sagen diese woche ist
interessante woche weil es hat am
dienstag bei uns im haus auch stark
gefunden eine arbeitsgruppe oder die die
gruppe militär und wirtschaft und die
vertreter aus der wirtschaft die da
waren haben in etwa
250.000 mitarbeiterinnen und mit dabei
repräsentiert das wort oberste chef der
strabag da ist war der oberste chef der
eta ist waren vertreter der post über
die infrastruktur und so weiter und so
fort da und wenn sie von der politischen
ebene immer wieder höhere
lehrverpflichtung milizübungen um gottes
willen also die in der wirtschaft wird
es nicht mitgetragen aus dem
persönlichen gesprächen kann ich euch
sagen
da dies gerade botschaft wenn hier eine
gesetzliche änderung dazu gegeben ist
dann wird das von der wirtschaft voll
mitgetragen und ich glaube in die
richtung müssen wir arbeiten wir müssen
die last die man dem einzelnen auferlegt
werde sich freiwillig verpflichtet und
dann zu seinem arbeitgeber geben und so
bitte ich habe mich freiwillig
verpflichtet sich fast entschuldigen
muss für etwas wofür die
österreichische bevölkerung und damit
sie die republik österreich für deren
sicherheit etwas tut vor dem müssen wir
wegkommen und dass jemand nimmt das muss
auch der vergangenheit angehören also
das wird ein prozessen das ist politisch
das bohren harter bretter nimmt es
vorweg aber daran werden wir weiter
arbeiten ich betone noch einmal in der
wirtschaft dieses argument lasse ich
nicht mehr gelten wer da bin ich jetzt
mittlerweile sehr sehr sicher und wenn
es in einzelfällen zu problemen kommt
das betrifft insbesondere kleinsten
unternehmungen dann haben wir beim
bundesheer mittlerweile in der
flexibilität wenn es um übungen geht im
einsatz ist das sowieso was anderes wenn
es um übungen geht dass man hier durch
diese flexibilität
da härtefälle vermeiden kann oder das
darf nicht die begründung dafür seien
das insgesamt nicht geht dass ein
wesentliches thema sehr stolz immer auch
das von diesem 200 millionen sonde
invest ag ist sich schon einiges getan
hat wo es um die verbesserung ist
insbesondere der strukturierten militär
geht wir haben mittlerweile 178 lkw sind
zugeliefert wurden klein kfz sind ab
heuer im zulauf
was tarnanzüge betrifft ist es auch so
das finde ich gut je nach
militärkommanden und privaten werden
auch da wird auch dazu da die miliz
gleichzeitig ausgestattet werden erste
verbände sind ja schon ausgestattet
zusätzlich
4800 stück modulare ballistischen
schutzwesten
18.000 neue kampf mit ausstattung der
miliz sind bestellt es sind
1689 brillen im zulauf damit hält man in
etwa 100 prozent dem diesbezüglich
abgedeckt es sind abc schutzmaske und
arbeitsschutz begleitung grundsätze für
das gesamte bund ist ja in beschaffung
und das geld gleichzeitig auch für die
milizen wird so also nicht irgendwelche
worte positionen geben
178 stück scharfschützengewehren
inklusive lese entfernungsmesser sind im
beschaffung
5680 stück und brüstung setzte
modifikation sturmgewehr ist geschafft
die modifikation des heeres intern
eingeleitet und auch was
verbindungssysteme etc betrifft sind das
2530 stück die da im zulauf sein werden
also man sieht
es ist etwas wirklich in bewegung
ich kann die zahlen deshalb nennen weil
ich gebeten habe dass diese zahlen zur
verfügung gestellt werden mit diesem
miliz paket ist ein erster schritt getan
mehr nicht aber wir müssen sie auch
positiv sehen also ein erster schritt
wurde gemacht wir sind am weg zur
materiellen einsatzbereitschaft und die
summe was wir sicher stellen müssen ist
gleichzeitig die personelle
einsatzbereitschaft und material und die
ausrüstung muss natürlich dann parallel
sein und wir sollten dann auch nicht
mehr unterscheiden zwischen
strukturierten an die miliz miliz
anteilen nein es geht um die miliz
und dieses sondern westpaket milit das
war auch ein 1
derzeit sei ein politischer deal weil
tagen konsens gefunden werden kann zu
sagen okay das machen wir aber jetzt
wenn diese budgets sich so entwickeln
als regel budget und diverse sondern
lässt dann geht es um das aus staaten
des österreichischen bundesheeres und da
darf es dann auch keinen unterschied
mehr geben aber wir werden ein auge
darauf haben dass das auch so
funktioniert und nur auch klar eine gut
ausgestattete truppe ist auch einsatz
nahe und kann damit auch üben
jetzt sorgt das üben mit folkgruppe der
general das ist auch eine einen
planungsstopp um es so zu sagen wir
wissen jetzt natürlich auch klar
aufgrund der laufenden zurückgehenden
des potenzials unserer unserer
einrückenden unserer grundwehrdienern es
ist schwierig aber
ich weiß auch dass man sich darüber
intensiv gedanken macht wir sollten auf
das wieder durchaus zurückkommen können
wie es vor 20 oder 30 jahren auch
tatsächlich
möglich war aber mir ist auch klar hat
auch budgetär implikationen aber damit
so das ja dann weiter möglich sein
beseitigung der sozialrechtlichen
nachteile ein ganz schwieriges thema ein
unangenehmes thema griff von allen
parteien selbstverständlich und machen
wir faktum ist bis zum heutigen tag
haben wir diese sogenannte legistik
paket noch nicht als resultat hier durch
das parlament beschlossen ich hatte in
der zwischenzeit ein gespräch mit dem
präsidenten des österreichischen
gewerkschaftsbundes mit präsident
katzian ich hatte gespräch mit dem
nationalratspräsidenten und ich hatte
ein gespräch mit den
klubobleuten also allemal versichert ist
es auf schiene aufgrund von
ministerwechsel rutscher natürlich
verschieben sich wieder schnittstellen
gehe auf die details nicht ein es ist
unglaublich aber
ich hoffe doch dass man das im heurigen
jahr jedenfalls parlamentarisch über die
bühne bringen diese zusage gibt es
weiter das thema miliz zertifizierung
der anerkennung und sichtbar machen und
es hat ihr heute bei media summit auch
wieder gebracht ist einfach wirklich
rüberzubringen
die militärische ausbildung welchen
zivilen wert hat die und das ist uns mit
dieser miliz zertifiziert und dank der
tüv akademie glaube ich wirklich gut
gelungen da gebührt wirklich ein großer
dank dem general wesley der sich ihrem
auslandseinsatz befindet der hat sich
darauf vor aufgeschmissen dass dieser
schritt also möglich war und wir haben
auch diese woche immer am dienstag
wurden auch wieder einige zertifikate
verliehen und wir haben auch dann die
unternehmens chefs und chefinnen die da
waren auch gesagt das sind sie froh dass
es jetzt was vorstellen können was man
da eigentlich leer und war man von
führungskompetenz rede wie kann man das
dann umsetzen ins zivile dafür ein
herzliches dankeschön das immer auch
wirklich einen großen schritt
vorangekommen und das werden wir weiter
vorantreiben und
ganz positiv und dafür auch ein
dankeschön
der information zum modul miliz miliz
wird miliz das wird auch von der frau
bundesminister das wurde auch und wird
vom generalstabschef
massivster unterstützt
das werden wir weiter
vorantreiben bis hinauf zur systemischen
verwendung vom linzer torten im miliz
service center auch das ist eine tolle
sache
die man erfunden hat im zuge dessen aus
dem eigenen heraus wie können wir denn
hier die miliz noch besser realisieren
ein unverzichtbarer beitrag und an
dieser stelle als heute nicht da möchte
ich mich auch bei privat japanern sehr
sehr bedanken abteilung mit ist die
ästhetische einsatz koordination weil er
es auch dann mit veranlasst hat die
implementierung der miliz elemente in
der zentralstelle
denn man kann vieles ansprechen nur wenn
sich das dann nicht im organigramm in
letzter konsequenz auch hochrangige
wieder findet dann bestätigt gefahr dass
das nicht weiter vorangetrieben wird die
anerkennung der leistungen milizen
wirtschaft habe ich schon gesprochen ich
glaube das sind wir jetzt wirklich auf
einem intensiven weg und ich kann sie
und euch nur wirklich auch bieten jeder
und jede auf der jeweiligen ebene in
seinem unternehmen dafür einzutreten
dass sichtbar zu machen und das weiter
voranzutreiben nur so kommen wir
wirklich hinter breite auch waren heute
der tag der miliz ist wir geben mit
uniform schon mal wird es ihr insgesamt
gesehen hat das hängt einfach mit der
struktur zusammen mit der struktur des
österreichischen bundesheeres mit der
sichtbarkeit
und daran müssen wir arbeiten wenn nur
so gelingt auch wirklich die akzeptanz
dann auch durchzudrücken und zu
erreichen und daher haben auch das thema
bildungsscheck miliz weiter
vorangetrieben das ist in einer
projektphase auf einer guten
projektphase damit soll auch das
milizsystem in der wirtschaft gefördert
werden und wir hatten die ehre dass der
ausbildungschef ist einfach und
personalverantwortliche der schweizer
armee bei uns bei unserem
bei unserer sitzung medizin wirtschaft
schöpft vorgetragen hat einige von euch
waren hat der bayern haben das gesehen
wie das funktioniert und mein ansatz war
ich kenne das jetzt seit einigen jahren
dass wir das so weit als möglich asia
kopie machen
aber natürlich auf das österreichische
bundesheer adaptiert und da sind wir auf
einem guten weg und auch die wie ich
mittlerweile weiß die arbeitgeber sehen
das sehr sehr positiv und
dass dieser
bildungsscheck in letzter konsequenz
eine win win situation ist jetzt gehört
dazu dass wir die leistungskriterien
dazu ausarbeiten
das österreichische bundesheer unsere
milizsoldaten bei der ausbildung dann
legt dieser anreiz soll auch ein
wirtschaftlicher vorteil für die
jeweilige person aber insbesondere für
das unternehmen seien zu einer
qualifizierten erwachsenenbildung um
nichts anderes geht es geht um eine
qualifizierte aus und weiterbildung
damit die erwachsenen bildung und wir
müssen auch dann noch fixieren die
maximale höhe des bildungsschecks aber
auch hier kann ich sagen das budget
werde ich nicht mehr akzeptieren dass
das irgendeinen punkt sein kann hat er
mehrere gespräche mit dem herrn
finanzminister auch jetzt wieder mit dem
herrn bundesminister bronner der sagt
okay wenn das vorliegt wir haben gesagt
es wird einen etwa und steckt sich sehr
mit der schweizer medien sind auch auf
diese zeilen interessanterweise gekommen
es geht um zirka 20 millionen euro und
er hat uns am dienstag auch gesagt dass
dieser ungefähr in dieser höhe in der
schweiz liegt also liegen wir sehr sehr
gut obwohl wir vom potenzial her in
wahrheit deutlich niedriger werden also
wird sind mit 20 glaube ich gut
aufgestellt dass wir werden das bekommen
und jetzt geht es darum
intensivst wirklich weiter zu arbeiten
und ziel ist es aus meiner sicht und und
ich glaube auch von euch das 20 23
hierbei eine umsetzungsphase
beginnt und wo wir auch noch nicht dort
sind es geht um das arbeiten
das zusätzliche arbeitsplätze zur
bearbeitung von miliz angelegenheiten im
ressort geschaffen werden
ich weiß aber das ist nicht das
eigentliche thema hier im haus sondern
das ist wieder in einem anderen ressort
zugeteilt wo es bis hin zu wertigkeiten
diskussionen gibt da müssen wir
gemeinsam weiterarbeiten die frau
bundesminister die oberste militärische
führung trägt das voll mit wir wissen
auch wo wie viel wer mit welcher
wertigkeit zu implementieren wäre damit
also die servicierung unserer
milizsoldaten
deutlich verbessert würde unsere
sogenannten mox sachbearbeiter design
aus meiner sicht die wichtigsten
bezugspersonen
außerhalb der kommandanten diese
natürlich führen es ist klar wenn es um
die laufende servizi rung geht wo eine
große übung ist dann sind das unsere
bezugspersonen für die milizsoldaten die
großen dank und anerkennung
verdienen aber jetzt muss man schauen
dass man die anzahl und die
entsprechenden wertigkeiten dafür
bekommen und damit habe ich die
wesentlichen themen aus meiner sicht
angesprochen
abschließend möchte ich noch auf die
nutzung der modularen und
offiziersausbildung auch hinweisen auch
da haben wir uns auf den weg gemacht
auch bar wurde ressort hinten sehr sehr
rasch reagiert
dankenswerterweise
hat auch hier auf der ausbildung seite
man dann rasch die die entsprechenden
rahmenbedingungen geschaffen
generalmajor studien hat es auch sehr
sehr unterstützt und daher general
brieger man hat auch gesehen wenn es
wirklich gewollt wird dann gibt es einen
ruck und basiert sehr häufig und rasch
aber
wieder die bitte an sie alle das muss es
auch nutzen ja es ist immer
etwas bedrückend wenn rahmenbedingungen
geschaffen wurden wo man dann hört man
ja nicht wirklich also wir sind auf
einem guten weg aber wie man so schön
sagt das darf deutlich mehr sein dann
und das ist der aufruf nutzt man die aus
und weiterbildungsmöglichkeiten die
militärisch uns für die einsatzfähigkeit
deutlich mehr
qualifizieren aber wie ich auch schon
gesagt habe das wird jetzt auch im
zivilen in ihrem beruf deutlich besser
erkannt werden das heißt diese brücke
können wir damit noch besser fragen und
in diesem sinne werden wir gemeinsam für
die miliz
verbessern wir weiter die möglichkeiten
das projekt an und zwei bin jetzt auf
diese vielen detail projekte jetzt nicht
eingegangen da wurde auch tolle arbeit
geleistet dass wir haben noch einmal ein
anderer stelle auch sicherlich
ansprechen aber da gibt auch mein großer
dank an alle ressort angehörigen
insbesondere hier in der zentralstelle
wo es möglich war diese vielzahl von
themen zu bearbeiten sehr konstruktiv zu
bearbeiten es waren viele von uns auch
mit eingebunden und dafür gebührt ein
großer dank und daher möchte ich jetzt
noch mal tanken da obersten ressort
führung unserer frau bundesministerin
die wirklich ein großes herz hat für die
miliz ihr gesamtes herz ihr gesamtes
engagement schlägt in ihrer politischen
verantwortung für das österreichische
bundesheer darum bin ich auch so
zuversichtlich dass ich da jetzt
wirklich einiges weiterentwickeln wird
wir sind dazu eingeladen das hat sie mir
auch wieder zum eintrag zum ausdruck
gebracht aktiv mitzuarbeiten und
einzubringen
und es geht nicht darum wo sie es nicht
gibt den ansatz hatte frau
bundesministerin überhaupt nicht sondern
sie sorgt sofort okay was können wir tun
damit das funktioniert also wie dinge
geht aber klar wir haben einen
gesetzlichen rahmen wurden unterscheiden
was können wir innerhalb des
gesetzlichen rahmens machen aber man ist
auch nicht abgeneigt im fall des falles
wenn es schwergewichtige argumente gibt
dass man auch eine gesetzesmaterie
selbstverständlich ändern kann
dass der banker die frau bundesminister
unter der dank gilt auch hier her
generalmajor dem herrn
general brieger den durfte ich das
oftmals sagen ein general industry
länger denn es ist wichtig dass wir
unsere anliegen auf der obersten ebene
einbringen können damit erspart man sich
einen langen dienstweg das ist keine
selbstverständlichkeit dass wir so
respektvoll und
freundschaftlich und kameradschaftlich
miteinander umgehen ich glaube das ist
auch ein gutes fundament und die basis
die wir brauchen um das österreichische
bundesheer gemeinsam wo es das
sicherheits instrument was die
strategische reserve der republik
österreich
zu positionieren und daher arbeiten wir
gemeinsam an der umfassenden
landesverteidigung und sehr spezifisch
arbeiten wir mit am thema
landesverteidigung in diesem sinne ein
herzliches danke ein herzlicher dank für
das unglaubliche engagement das sich
immer wieder spüre und
gemeinsam sie immer unterwegs die
sicherheit der republik österreich und
damit die resilienz
für die österreichische bevölkerung
weiter zu entwickeln und
wieder zu einem status zu kommen wo wir
auch nach außen glaubwürdig versichern
können im fall des falles sind wir
vorbereitet und dass sein fall eintreten
kann dass sie mir jeden tag vielen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin vom dienst ab korporal auf dem
weg zum wachtmeister und im zivilen
leben sinnlos
[Musik]
ich habe grundwehrdienst absolviert habt
dann abgerüstet und dann habe ich mich
in frieden okay es wäre doch eine gute
alternative oder einer option
und seitdem bin ich aktiv dabei
[Musik]
also die modulare ausbildung hat
besonders eben für berufstätige den
vorteil dass diese blöcke mit eigentlich
fast jedem dienstgeber irgendwie
vereinbar sind ich muss es nicht diese
vier bzw mit den vier modulen zwei
module also in sechs module in summe
muss ich nicht in einem jahr schaffen
sondern ich habe vier jahre in seit
diese blöcke hinter mir zu bringen was
glaube ich für fast jeden eigentlich
irgendwie machbar ist beruflich und
familiär
[Musik]
es gibt unzählige erlebnisse und
ereignisse von denen glaube ich jeder
medizin kamerad berichten kann in der
miliz gibt es eine tolle kameradschaft
und dann ein auch schon in diesem kurs
gestern zum beispiel beim gefechtes
dienst hatten wir eine sehr lehrreiche
zeit aber auch eine sehr unterhaltsame
zeit
[Musik]
also sich besonders an der miliz schätze
ist die vielfalt dass alle altersgruppen
vertreten sind das die menschen
herkommen kameradschaftlich miteinander
sitzen sich gegenseitig ergänzen und das
beste einfach auf einen einsatz machen
teil der miliz zu sein bedeutet für mich
einzigartige kameradschaft und einsatz
für österreich
[Musik]
dies bedeutet für mich herzblut und
genauso gute freundschaft über alle
grenzen hinweg
[Musik]
ja werte zuseherinnen und zuseher werte
kameraden wir danken recht herzlich
unserem über seit mehreren jahren und
jahrzehnten engagierten
mitglieds beauftragte generalmajor
hannes eder für seine unterstützung er
hat immer ein offenes ohr für die
anliegen insbesondere der verpflichtung
ihres besitzstandes und eine sache ist
auch wirklich klar wir sind ein
bundesheer durch sind sehr stolz darauf
dass wir eben 50 prozent des personals
für die innen und auslandseinsätze und
die last die seit mehreren jahren sehr
sehr hoch weil wir eben auch die kurven
19 pandemie mehr mittragen mussten wir
sind zum teil bis zu 2300 kameraden kann
man jeden tag 24 stunden im einsatz und
das kann man nur gemeinsam schaffen
die aufgaben gehen uns nicht aus
trotzdem sehen wir sehr stolz dass wir
als österreichisches bundesheer die
kaderschmiede auch für
führungspersönlichkeiten sind das
beginnt bei einem ganz tollen angebot
das hat kein unternehmen oder kann man
unternehmen kann seine privatwirtschaft
anbieten nämlich für diese große gruppe
der mannschaft zum chargen dienstgraden
das sind kameraden man kann mal haben es
sind zwischen 18 und 30 jahre alt ganz
offen in der privatwirtschaft wird das
erste mal geld in die hand genommen für
eine führungsausbildung da ist man 30
mitte 30 ihr müsst euch ein bundesheer
bekommen sie das bereits mit 18 19 20
jahren mit echter führungserfahrung und
auf das so wahnsinnig stolz und für
diese bedarfsträger gruppe nämlich für
die wehrpflichtigen des mittelstandes
und hierfür die mannschaft von chargen
dienst gerade hat ist ein großer wurf
gelungen dank auch der unterstützung von
unserem mix beauftragten gemeinsam mit
ihr generalmajor besser die nämlich eine
berufs vermeintliche modulare
medizinprofessors ausbildung zu
generieren ja genau das wurde geschaffen
vor wenigen jahren neben der kader
anwärter ausbildung die ja die normale
ausbildung für die unteroffiziere und
offiziere es egal ob berufsstand oder
miliz stand darstellt gibt es eben jetzt
wieder eine modulare miliz unter
offiziersausbildung ein sehr sehr
wichtiger schritt
ganz besonders wichtig ist dass sie
berufs freundlich ist das heißt keines
der ausbildungsmodule dauert länger als
zwei wochen das gilt übrigens auch für
die miliz offiziersausbildung hier gilt
auch der besondere dank an die milak und
daniela back und an die an die drucken
schulen weil keines der ausbildung
seminare länger als zwei wochen dort ja
und wofür werden wir ausgebildet für den
einsatz und deshalb sind wir sehr stolz
heute als unseren gastvortrag an
generalmajor hofbauer bei uns willkommen
zu heißen generalmajor
versuche sie mit ihrem vortrag über den
klassischen konflikt in der ukraine zu
beginnen dankeschön
ja danke für die feindliche anmoderation
der krieg in der ukraine hat er am 24
februar uns alle ein wenig gerüttelt die
einen mehr die anderen weniger ich
möchte auch nicht verhehlen dass sich
selbst persönlich obwohl ich immer schon
etwas mit einem stillen auge richtung
osten geschaut habe über überrascht war
über die härte und den umfang des
angriffes den die
russische föderation hier gegen die
ukraine vorgetragen hat
ja
jetzt sei aber keine präsentation
mitgebracht und würde sie in den
nächsten minuten ganz kurz
informieren wollen nächste folie bitte
über die
aktuelle situation in der ukraine ohne
jetzt massiv in die operation die
entwicklung der operativen lage der
letzten wochen einzugehen sondern noch
mal zu beschreiben wo wir heute stehen
aber vor allem die auswirkungen auf das
österreichische bundesheer wo ich schon
denke dass das insgesamt großes thema
für die nächsten jahre für uns sein wird
und für gewisse gewisse bereiche
auch entsprechend nachschärfen werden
müssen wenn sich auch grundsätzlich an
der position österreichs in der mitte
europas geografischer nichts geändert
hat und weise aber auch vom
sicherheitsumfeld wir nach wie vor von
eu nato staaten umgeben sind mit
ausnahme der schweiz hier nicht in der
nato ist aber im endeffekt wie
österreich nach wie vor kein fan stadt
ist so beschützt wie es schließlich
stellt sich die aktuelle lage dar am 24
februar hat im endeffekt ein sehr
umfassender an vier front abschnitten
vor angetragener ansatz der russischen
streitkräfte
richtung ukraine zugetragen es war
offensichtlich die absicht rasch eine
entscheidung herbeizuführen vor allem
kiew im besitz zu nehmen das politische
und wirtschaftliche zentrum der ukraine
das ist nicht gelungen die dort geplante
luft landen konnte
bekämpft werden und zwar dermaßen dass
es nicht gelungen ist wenn du den
russischen luftfahrt kräften weitere
kräfte hierhin nach zu führen die
bereits im anmarsch oder beziehungsweise
im anflug befindlichen großen illusionen
transportmaschinen organisierte assets
an bord gehabt hätten mussten wieder
umkehren und in weiterer folge wurde der
angriff im norden bis an die orts ränder
von kiefer die schatten
von von kiew herangetragen im osten der
ansatz bis noch aktiv das befindet sich
hier im osten der ukraine
der ton war als wesentlicher abschnitt
und ein sehr erfolgreicher ansatz aus
der krim heraus richtung norden über die
weiteren wochen hat sich dann im
endeffekt fahren an den städten die
situation so
zugetragen dass ein an ein
durchsetzungsfähiger angriff ein
erfolgreicher angriff der russischen
streitkräfte hier nicht möglich war und
man ende märz den entschluss geführt hat
offenbar die kräfte so zu konzentrieren
dass zumindest ein überblick baarer
angriffs erfolg im südosten sprich im
donbass erzielt werden konnte im süden
ist es gelungen hier an den metro
vorzustoßen die ein laufwerke für den
nordkanal in besitz zu nehmen sehr rasch
und hier auch eine der lebensadern vor
allem für den handel nämlich keine
binnenschiffahrt mehr auf den titel
unter kontrolle zu bekommen und
gleichzeitig den rest der
schwarzmeerküste einer blockade zu
unterziehen wir sehen sehr viele bilder
aus der ukraine und hoffe dass das jetzt
funktioniert die nächste folie bitte
was können wir sehen
wir sehen
vielmehr aus diesem konflikt dass wir
üblicherweise an bildern und
informationen über einen bewaffneten
militärischen konflikt bisher gesehen
haben als ein beispiel die aus der
ukraine
der einsatz von drohnen gegen einen
russischen verfügung sei er zunächst zur
aufklärung genutzt wird und damit dann
artilleriefeuer entsprechend
angefangen angefordert wird und dass
auch eine entsprechende wirkung zeigt
das heißt wir haben die verknüpfung von
relativ alten einsatzmitteln spricht der
artillerie beteilt weise sogar tot
gesagt weil wer braucht heute noch
artillerie und modernen mitteln und dem
modernen mitteln sind nicht nur die
aufklärungs fähigkeit und rasche führung
informations fähigkeit über thronen und
digitale metal management systems
sondern auch punktgenau wir kennen die
artillerie die hier durch die ukraine
eingesetzt wird
wenn wir zum nächsten video übergehen
dann sehen sie hier
vermutlich eine auf ein bild von einem
organisierten angriff
die brauchen aber
nie toyota fuß immer als indie und klein
ist das glück zur seite brunnen einsetzt
um einen regulierten angriff schon
gesprochen
freundlicherweise
vorgetragen noch sonst eine brutto da
war der master verboten
entsprechend dürfen tage lang getagt
reviews das heißt wir sehen hier gehabt
dass nicht nur
die eine technologie zum erfolg der
produktion maik bahr rechnet auch eine
andere aktive und gefechts technische
handeln auf russischer seite dazu
beigetragen hat dass sie entsprechende
verluste aber auch der angriff nicht so
vorangekommen ist wie man sich das
vorgestellt hat erst jetzt ab mai sind
nur wirklich ernstzunehmende bilder von
entfalteten und entwickelten
mechanisierten groß verband
organisierten verbänden die hier
unterwegs sind und ich habe noch ein
letztes video mitgebracht
jawohl
von der russischen seite aus gefilmt und
hier die beiden das sind ukrainer
kampf in der nacht
mit dem entsprechenden ergebnis wenn der
eine in der nacht zieht ankämpfen kann
unter anderem nicht ist es natürlich ein
erheblicher nachteil für die
einsatzführung
und es muss uns klar sein dass hier
entsprechend nachzusteuern ist dass das
schwergewicht dass hier der generalmajor
vorhang
angezogen dass hier auch im bundesheer
in die nachtsicht und nacht kam
fähigkeit investiert wird ist jedenfalls
ein gebot der stunde
und die darf bieten auf die nächste
folie weiterzugehen noch eine weiter
bitte
ganz großer aspekt der uns jedenfalls in
der ukraine begegnet ist ist der krieg
der bilder wir haben im endeffekt
gewohnt aus kriegsgebieten eigentlich
eher gefilterte informationen zu
bekommen das hat sich in der ukraine
durch die möglichkeit dass weiterhin
kommuniziert wird und das nicht irgendwo
in einem abgelegenen
raum passiert und es müssen uns ganz
einfach in europa auch gewöhnen dass das
informations umfeld einfach vorhanden
ist das
entsprechende
meldungen berichte filme fotos
tonaufnahmen über die sozialen medien
tik tok telegramm juni mit wasser stahel
es gibt entsprechend hereinkommen auch
bei uns in der in der auswertung ist
dass er ganze
geschichte war im endeffekt lange
auswerten muss wer schickt welche
informationen zu welchem zweck ist es
überhaupt real wo findet das statt wann
war das und hat es vielleicht hat
zweiter auch noch gesehen weil sie
erinnern sich vielleicht auf die
ankündigungen des präsidenten putin am
noch vor der invasion dass diese truppe
zurückgezogen worden werden würden und
da sind dann noch fotos oder
filmaufnahmen gezeigt worden von einer
bahn
eisenbahn mit panzern beladener niemand
konnte sagen welche
welche welcher zug mit welcher richtung
wer sagt dass der nicht in die
gegenrichtung gefahren ist das trifft
sowohl die politische führung und ich
denke dass wir hier dem ukrainischen
staatspräsidenten der im endeffekt
das ganz massiv in seiner kern rolle
hier gespielt hat mit dem handy
durchgehend die bevölkerung gerade in
der ersten phase des konflikts
informiert hat wir sind handlungsfähig
wir werden uns und das wirkt sich
natürlich sowohl auf der bevölkerung in
den widerstandswillen aber auch
logischerweise eigentlich soldaten aus
stellen sie sich vor dass das nicht
passiert worden passiert wäre ich denke
dass eine inbesitznahme kiew sehr
schnell zu einem anderen kriegsverlauf
hätte führen können wir haben aber auch
andere bilder auf der anderen seite ein
sehr langer tisch oder russische
staatspräsident den
verteidigungsminister und den kanal
stabschef hier offensichtlich auf
distanz hält auch das sind entsprechende
bilder die wahrzunehmen sind auf der
nächsten folie möchte allerdings eines
betonen dass aber diese beispiele
gebracht dass wir jetzt bitte keine
voreiligen schlüsse ziehen
das österreichische bundesheer braucht
jetzt nicht zum jagd haben vor über zu
gehen weil demnächst russische schwere
angriffs kräfte über die eisenstädter
vorne fahren will wir müssen uns nur
damit anfreunden dass wir hier erstens
einmal mitten in europa und nicht
irgendwo in einem land weit weg in
syrien afghanistan oder in afrika einen
bewaffneten konflikt haben dass wir in
europa offensichtlich vor nicht nur
gröberen wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
umbrüchen stehen sondern wir eigentlich
aus meiner sicht am anfang eines neuen
kalten krieges stehen wo die von und
dermaßen
verhärtet sind dass sich für die
nächsten jahre keine unmittelbare
verhandlungslösung sehe sie müssen auch
bedenken dass beinahe alle
vertrauensbildenden maßnahmen die
zwischen ost und west ausgemacht wurden
bis hin zur überprüfung oder zur
inspektion von übungen ausgesetzt wurden
oder ausgesetzt sind und nur mit einem
nuklearen bereich einzelne verträge
bestehen das heißt das lagebild ist
nicht einfacher geworden sondern
komplizierter und die bedrohungen die
heute durch an durch das was wir
wahrnehmen und wofür in den medien platz
ist spricht die ukraine die drohende
ressourcenknappheit teuerung die
inflation dass er das nur alle die dinge
zu deckt die vorher thema worden es ist
ja nicht so dass es keinen terrorismus
mehr gebe und leider sahen wir gestern
mit dem beispiel in berlin durchaus
wieder damit konfrontiert worden dass
auch das mitten in europa stattfinden
kann wir haben einen zufluss von
entsprechenden flüchtlingsströmen zu
erwarten wenn sich die welt
ernährungssituation nur einigermaßen in
die richtung wie sie von der uno derzeit
beurteilt wird entwickelt das sind ja
bedrohungen und risiken mit denen wir in
weiterer folge umgehen müssen und
hinzukommen unangenehmer weise alle die
sachen diana dors an nämlich der kampf
um und mit information der kampf im
cyberspace und die ganze frage wie zum
beispiel man in zukunft mit solchen
systemen die unbemannt sind
umgehen möchte nächste folie somit
möchte ich kurz zusammenfassen hier die
traditionellen militärische bedrohung
ist nicht verschwunden wird aber noch
neue mittel entsprechend verstärkt was
heißt das jetzt fürs bundesheer
es bedeutet für uns nächste volle bitte
dass wir
jedenfalls einen beurteilungs prozess
auslösen müssen beziehungsweise das was
bisher berichtet wird wurde überprüft zu
überprüfen haben und darauf möchte jetzt
ganz kurz eingehen erste erstens bitter
wir haben eine grundsätzlich
verschlechternde sicherheitslage rund um
österreich eine verschärfte
ost-west-konfrontation die jetzt
bahnsport ins militärische umgesprungen
ist wir haben
eine ungleich gewichtung in dem was wir
an ressourcen verbrauchen in europa und
was unter anderem unter anderem andere
uns zur verfügung stellen wollen wir
sollten hier dann nicht ganz china
indien und andere staaten aus der
gleichung draußen lassen österreich ist
allerdings weiterhin kein frontstaat das
heißt die hinwendung zu einer
konventionellen landesverteidigung mit
all den fragen die daran hängen eine
höhere mechanisierung etc diese frage
stellt sich aus meiner sicht derzeit
noch nicht weil im endeffekt wird damit
rechnen müssen dass am ende das bier in
die tiefe bewirkt werden und der
streitkräfte profil unser her dass durch
die bundesministerin voriges jahr
angeordnet wurde ist erstaunlich
vorausblickend formuliert geworden dass
im endeffekt das relativ gut abgedeckt
ist was wir als österreichische
bundesheer leisten sollen und wenn die
finanziellen mittel die jetzt durch das
wachrütteln durch die ukraine
angekündigt worden kommen dann wird es
für das bundesheer und ganz gezielt für
das bundesheer und die rede jetzt nicht
von dem präsidenten oder den miliz
anteilen oder der reserve dann geht dann
müssen wir das gesamte bundesheer
entsprechend ausstatten ausrüsten aber
es geht auch um das personal gewinnen
das personal halten in der organisation
und die entsprechende ausbildung
sicherstellen modernes gerät braucht der
menge ausbildung nächste folie bitte der
hybride konflikt erfordert eine
umfassende landesverteidigung ich sage
jetzt noch einmal es haben sich die
dinge die sich bis zum 24
februar entwickelt haben nicht aufgelöst
man hat nur ein bisschen aus den
gedanken gestrichen neue job anschlag in
großbritannien das abschließen einer
niederländischen passagiermaschine das
hinrichten eines aus russischer seite
gesehen
tschetschenen in
berlin das sind ja alles dinge die
passiert sind bis hin zur frage ob an
der explosion in tschechien dort
geheimdienstliche aktivitäten zu
verorten sind diebe wirkung von
desinformations raums in europas die
unterstützung für extreme rechte und
linke gruppierungen in europa das ist ja
deshalb nicht weg und wir müssen das ist
was hybride betreuung bedeutet das
wirtschaftlich maßnahmen gesetzt werden
politische maßnahmen gesetzt werden dass
im informationsraum bewirkt wird und das
militär ist dann nur das letzte fenster
mit man das geht und somit ist ganz klar
wie ich eingangs schon erwähnt hat dass
die geistige wirtschaftliche zivile und
militärische landesverteidigung
gemeinsam weiterzuentwickeln sagen und
bei der wirtschaftlichen
landesverteidigung sagen wir jetzt
leider
aufgewacht
in einer dimension die wir aus meiner
sicht noch gar nicht abschätzen können
das heißt diese neukonzeption das ist
dringend angesagt ist ein
gesamtstaatlich ansatz notwendig dass
ein staatliches risiko und beurteilungs
prozess sowie eine ordentliche
verteidigung im luftraum selber und
informations umfeld erhöht
bekommt eine erhöhte bedeutung heißt
nicht dass es die alleine sind mich ja
nicht falsch zu verstehen wir brauchen
den ordentlichen force mix und das sind
landluft selber kräfte und menschen die
sich im informationsraum auskennen zwei
fohlen mit folgerungen das muss das
bundesheer leisten können es muss fähig
sein zum kampf es muss durchhaltefähig
sein reaktionsfähig und sich durchsetzen
können alles nur durch schutz
zu wollen das hat noch nie zum erfolg
geführt langfristig man muss sich auch
wehren können das heißt es geht immer um
schutz und wirkung und nicht nur um ein
gepanzertes fahrzeug sondern um ein
gepanzertes fahrzeug das abschießen kann
des weiteren muss das bundesheer weiter
bitte autark sein
interoperabel innovativ und
früherkennung steak autark wir müssen
handeln können wenn alles andere nicht
mehr funktioniert wir haben das ein
bisschen über die
diskussion über den blackout auch
versucht aus dem militär heraus zu
lancieren nicht um zu sagen das
bundesheer löst das problem sondern
bereiten wir uns darauf vor damit es
nicht so schlimm wird wenn sie eintritt
und das bundesheer kommt in einer zeit
rolle hier zum einsatz interoperabel
international wie national
natürlich innovativ ist das bundesheer
und auch hier spielt die melitta große
rolle weil die miliz die möglichkeit
bietet das was als persönliches know how
vorhanden ist ein die militärische
organisation hineinzubringen das hat
immer sehr gute diskussionen die mit
milizsoldaten geführt werden naja die
dinge sehr oft sehr anders sind als wir
somit geht es um die umsetzung des
streitkräfte profils das bundesheer ist
derzeit weiter bitte damit beschäftigt
aus diesen schriften profil der inlands
und die auslands ambitionen klar zu
definieren was muss alles gleichzeitig
wie lange wie autark und wie schnell
aufholen und entsprechende
priorisierungen werden wir hier
durchführen
zudem priorisierungen kann ich sie
informieren auf der nächsten folie dass
im endeffekt
die ganze aufklärungs fähigkeit des
österreichischen bundesheeres von
militärstrategischen dienst bis zum
aufklärungs zug im kleinen verband eine
hohe und höchste priorität hat wir
müssen ein lagebild herstellen können es
geht um große räume es geht um eine
unsichere lage wir wissen nicht wann wer
wo angriff greift und mit welchem
verfahren und somit brauchen sie
aufklärungskräfte logischerweise der
kampf im cyberspace und diebe wirkung
informations umfeld der einsatz für im
urbanen raum
rainer suchan alle meine kameraden dem
weg vom kampf im wald wir müssen und das
zeigt uns die ukraine jahr wieder ja und
wie viele beispiele vorher nur da ist
halt sehr offensichtlich wir müssen uns
mit dem kampf um u bahn haben
auseinandersetzen ich bin dahinter dass
wir die orts kampf möglichkeiten für das
österreichische bundesheer entsprechend
ausbauen das nicht nur in bruck bzw es
in allen stark was ist dass wir im süden
was bekommen und auch im westen das
qualifiziert hier
soldaten entsprechend ausgebildet werden
können drohnen zur aufklärung fähigkeit
und andere möglichkeiten auch damit wir
zu verfolgen logischerweise wenn sie
mich fragen sollen wir träumen bewaffnen
warum nicht logischer weise werden wir
das tun drohnen abwehr und boden
gebundene luftabwehr ausbauen und sie
sagt noch mal das ist bereits voriges
jahr verabschiedet worden und die
ukraine hat das bestätigt das heißt
unsere planungen seien nicht ganz
daneben gewesen und gestatten sie mir
noch zweitletzte anmerkungen zum
abschluss erstens nächste folie bitte
das bundesheer von morgen ist nicht das
problem sehr von gestern die technologie
die digitalisierung hat einzug gehalten
und die landstreitkräfte sind heute mit
dem gleichen systemen konfrontiert
beinahe wie die luftstreitkräfte und
diallo ist nicht der 169 der neue
hubschrauber ist folge geht arisiert der
andere ist voll nicht digital und das
gleiche gilt auch für die
landstreitkräfte moderne systeme worden
entsprechend andere wartungsintervalle
haben einen höheren aufwand auf der an
das müssen wir uns erst gewöhnen und das
ist aus meiner sicht für die miliz agan
sehr große herausforderung meine
forderung gehabt es auch bei der
wirtschaft entsprechend so lanciert wir
brauchen einfache systeme wir müssen in
der lage sein nicht die ersten zwar
übungstagen und wieder damit
auseinanderzusetzen wie das funkgerät
funktioniert sondern das so
funktionieren wie ein iphone
selbsterklärend ohne werbung zu machen
könnte auch ein anderes mobiltelefon
sein dass im endeffekt den soldaten
unterstützt und nicht belastet und die
zweite der zweite punkt das aus meiner
sicht und ich denke dass ich da nicht
allen innern in die gleiche in das
gleiche horn blasen und du hast das
sagte generalmajor bitte die nächste
folie die fähigkeit zum kampf das müssen
wir wieder beleben und dazu müssen wir
üben und logischerweise ist die übungs
pflicht das durchführen regelmäßiger
truppenübungen eine voraussetzung dafür
dass überhaupt auf der ebene der
kompanie im bundesheer wieder sachen
passieren erstens brauchen wir die
soldaten die zur übung kommen und
zweitens müssen wir nicht nur auf der
ebene group bezug dinge tun oder
kompanie sondern wir brauchen die
bataillone brigade übungen die im
endeffekt des bundesheer dazu befähigen
dass der ist nämlich wieder zahlen
bringen den kampf der verbundenen waffen
zu führen wird dafür sind wir da das ist
unser alleinstellungsmerkmal
alles andere können andere auch und
vermutlich billiger als wir bei general
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren das
beendet meine kurzen ausführungen zu
kennen und zu den folgen und womit wir
uns derzeit geschafft befassen
dankeschön
[Applaus]
der general war vielen dank für ihre
ausführungen
hochinteressant wie sie waren mitten in
der lage in der ukraine
in diesem krieg wir haben die
ableitungen für das österreichische
bundesheer für uns ab personen gehört
die disziplin ist sehr hoch und auch das
vertrauen in die militärische führung
und das auch vollkommen zu recht denn
hier wurden die wesentlichen punkte
erkannt und hier auch beurteilt unter
richtig angesprochen ja in einer
krisenhaften situation braucht man in
allererster linie hier einen
entscheidenden
kampfkraft und auch einen kampf wert und
da stecken natürlich auch personen
dahinter und das was jetzt seit mehreren
jahren glücklicherweise auf eine
initiative von johannesburg zurückgeht
ist das ganz hervorragende projekt miliz
wird - hier geht es um die ständige
personalgewinnung man darf ja nicht
vergessen dass hier die mannschaft von
chargen dienst gerade alle sechs bis
sieben jahre hinaus rollieren und damit
beginnt man eigentlich wieder mit einem
wissenstand der aufzubauen ist und zum
anderen geht es um eine konsequente
personalbindung insbesondere von
erfahrenen kameradinnen und kameraden
denen man auch die möglichkeit geben
muss sich in ihrer funktion hier zu
entwickeln und weiter bieten zu können
johannes ich habe letztes jahr 20 21 410
kameraden kameraden in ganz österreich
geworden ja das ist korrekt und ich darf
da gleich noch ein paar anmerkungen
machen zu dem thema wir haben es ja
heute schon von mehreren vortragenden
gehört wir haben keine miliz übungs
verpflichtung umso wichtiger ist es dass
wir speziell in diesen zeiten heraus
gehen wir die melitia und auch werbung
machen für uns selbst und das passiert
in großem maße in ganz österreich
mittlerweile
über 200 engagierte mit soldaten und der
miliz ein gesicht geben und zum beispiel
unserer kameraden aus dem ding stand bei
vorträgen vor grund verdienen aber auch
bei der stellungs kommission etc
unterstützen und somit bekommen wir mehr
leute im system die dann
dehnübungen dabei sind und somit eine
höhere einsatzbereitschaft der
einsatzorganisation sicherstellen ja
absolut ein großes thema auch ist
natürlich die wertschätzung information
und kommunikation
ja genau es geht im grunde geht es immer
um kommunikation kommunikation ist alles
wie bringe ich die
information an den mann an die frau und
dazu gibt es auch eine andere initiative
nämlich das mmk das informationsportal
miliz wurde damals im märz 2020
aufgestellt auf über eine zentrale
stelle mit den zwei ganz zentralen
aufträgen erster die informationshoheit
des bundesministeriums für
landesverteidigung
insbesondere in krisenhaften situationen
sicher zu stellen das ist gelungen und
hier als drehscheibe zwischen dem
bundesministerium für landesverteidigung
und den wehrpflichtigen des
mittelstandes jetzt gehen und das ist
auch ein beitrag dieses produkt das wir
heute hier bieten sie können heute hier
live dabei sein wir haben sehr
interessante vortragender gehabt und
haben ganz klar herausgearbeitet dass es
darum geht wenn wir unsere aufgaben
erfüllen wollen dann brauchen wir die
personelle die materie
einsatzbereitschaft wie sie zum thema
personelle einsatzbereitschaft da gibt
es auch mehrere initiativen
interessensvertretungen die viel
freizeit aufbringen um ihre interessen
das netzwerk aber auch die unterstützung
hier gerade ziehen und ich darf jetzt
überleitung zum talk darf zu mir bitten
herrn viel zu deuten und richard
und ich darf zu mir bitten herrn fuchs
und frau
herzog sie sind präsident der
österreichischen gesellschaft und diese
chargen gesellschaft gibt es ja noch
nicht so lange wollen sie das vielleicht
einmal sich selber und auch die chargen
gesellschaft kurz vorstellen ja zuerst
einmal ein herzliches danke für die
einladung ist ist für uns eine große
ehre hier offiziell sprechen zu dürfen
zu meiner person er hat vor allem ein
name zugführer dienstgrad und ich bin vp
im ressort in der direktion 7 also die
chargen gesellschaft die wurde ja nicht
nur von mir gegründet es haben sich ca
20 25 engagierte mit auch milizsoldaten
hauptsächlich natürlich zusammengefunden
im mitte des jahres 2019 also knapp drei
jahre gibt es mittlerweile ja so wird
und wie kann man sie findet man sie im
internet und und und wie wird man bei
der faschingsgesellschaft überhaupt
mitglied also wir haben natürlich eine
eigene homepage www arischen
gesellschaft.de man findet sie uns auch
auf facebook soziale medien sind
heutzutage sehr wichtig wir schon heute
gehört haben und es gibt natürlich die
möglichkeit schriftlich über ein
formular oder auch eine online
möglichkeit wo es eigentlich fast
täglich mein handy läutet weil neuen
mitglieds anfragen kommen täglich neue
mitglieds anfragen das hört sich gut an
wie viele mitglieder haben sie dann
schon also mittlerweile wie gesagt knapp
drei jahre bestehen wir und es war ist
ein sehr großer andrang immer noch und
wir kratzen mittlerweile an die 1000
aktive mitglieder das ist eine sehr
beachtliche zahl für einen verein der
erst seit drei jahren besteht was sind
eigentlich die ziele der
österreichischen gesellschaft also die
ziele sind eigentlich nichts anderes als
die anerkennung der chargen als rückgrat
des bundesheers wie wir zb heute gehört
haben knapp 36.000 milizsoldaten und von
diesen 36.000 sind 80 prozent schaffen
also 29.000 soldatinnen und soldaten des
standes sind des mannschafts
beziehungsweise schon dienst gerade mal
gehörig und die wollen wir vertreten und
natürlich auch unterstützen als
networking und tutorin organisation in
diverse fragen zum beispiel zu erklären
oder auch natürlich die mopo zu
unterstützen um ihnen diese fragen
gleich vorab abzunehmen also sie haben
so quasi ein inoffizielles mentorin
system eingeführt indem sie ihre den
kameraden beraten kann man so sagen kann
man ihnen so wir sagen also ist ein
großes netzwerk bei uns kann wie gesagt
jeder mitglied werden wir haben vom
rekruten bis zum brigadier nahtlos alle
dienstgrade vertreten und was auch sehr
wichtig ist natürlich dieses netzwerk
dadurch kann man einige sachen im
vorfeld schon klären unter den kameraden
und muss nicht das system extra noch
belasten was wir heute ja schon gehört
haben und wir haben auch ein video dazu
gesehen ist die modulare miliz unter
offiziersausbildung das trifft jetzt
natürlich genau die chargen die ja in
weiterer folge zu und offizieren
herangeführt werden sollen
wie sehen sie diese ausbildung sehen sie
das positiv das ist endlich gekommen ist
also ich sehe es als positiv wir haben
natürlich an der gestaltung haben wir
auch mitbieten dürfen das war für uns
eine große ehre aber es war im grunde
nichts anderes wie die die notwendige
lösung das wirklich sehr starken abgang
von unteroffizieren und offizieren
aufgrund der geburtenstarken jahrgänge
selber persönlich habe ich wie man auch
im video gesehen hat schon einige dieser
module selber hinter mich gebracht es
sind sehr sehr gute module eine
hochachtung wirklich an die einheiten
und an die ausbilder es ist sicher nicht
leicht innerhalb dieser kurzen zeit der
kurse zwei wochen dieses wirklich
fundierte wissen und können an die
angehenden lied und offiziersanwärter
weiterzugeben und das war wirklich sehr
gut danke das ist nur natürlich eine
forderung von vielen
interessensvertretungen dass wieder eine
einführung dieser modularen blick 42
ausbildung kommt danke auch in diesem
zusammenhang für das engagement
sie waren ja soweit ich weiß selbst im
einsatz in kuwait einsatz hat es da
erfahrungen gegeben weil wir es heute
auch schon gehört haben unterschied
befristet und befristet geordnete was
ist ihre meinung dazu ja ich war selber
auch im coebad einsatz oder cobit hat
mich sehr extrem getroffen ich war fast
entsandt satz und nach dann im einsatz
präsenzdienst es waren natürlich sehr
sehr viele nicht befristet
milizangehörige dabei und ich muss sagen
natürlich aufgrund der motivation der
beamten haben dann eigentlich
schlussendlich bei uns in einer
komponiert beziehungsweise bataillon
haben fast bis auf ganz wenige ich habe
zwei oder drei personen haben nicht für
die unterschrieben dass sie beordert
werden wollen und man hat gezeigt dass
es geht wirklich über motivation ist
jetzt nicht unbedingt eine finanzielle
motivation sondern diese kameradschaft
und muss man leben und den leuten auch
weiter geben und es ist sehr positiv
dass jetzt sehr viele dann doch geworben
werden für befristete beorderte
ja das verstehen wir danke wir sehen
auch hier ein rekrutierungs potenzial
bei den befristeten orderten und auch
der präsident der bayerischen
gesellschaft arbeitet dem projekt miliz
wird medizin entsendet hier kameraden
welt diese chance natürlich sehr nahe an
den jungen kameraden an den grund
geringer 30 wie kann man die
österreichischen gesellschaft
unterstützen naja unterstützung gibt es
natürlich vielfältige möglichkeiten als
verein sind wir natürlich für jede
finanziellen beitrag natürlich dankbar
das sagen wir nicht nein aber das
wichtigste ist nicht das finanzielle es
ist die mitarbeit wie gesagt es ist
nicht wert und tutorin wir brauchen
leute die zu den stammtischen kommen die
den jungen oder den älteren oder wer
immer es gibt auch spätberufene dann
diverse wege oder sonstiges erklären wir
leben von einem netzwerk das ist das
wichtigste innerhalb des ressorts haben
wir aufgrund des der möglichkeit partner
des bundesheeres zu werden spricht das
waren früher die wer politisch
relevanten vereine haben wir jetzt mit
der harris logistik schule einen sehr
wertvollen partner gefunden besonders
weil natürlich über die logistik sehr
sehr viele chancen auch in den und
offiziers dienstgrad dann wandern werden
wir möchten aber für das ressort
generell und für spam mail verfahren für
die kommandanten wollen wir keine
belastung sein im gegenteil wir wollen
konstruktive mitarbeiter wir wollen
mitarbeiten zu arbeiten das dann diverse
würden vielleicht schon im vorfeld gar
nicht entstehen ja es ist das netzwerk
das die miliz stark gemacht danke herzog
ferner dass sie heute hierher gekommen
sind dass sie die initiative ergriffen
haben die chargen gesellschaft zu
gründen ist wirklich eine tolle
erfolgsgeschichte auch mit bereits knapp
1000 mitgliedern eine gruppe die bisher
nicht vertreten war als
interessensvertretung vielen dank dafür
ich glaube das hat sich einen applaus
verdient
und ich darf das wort jetzt übergeben an
major stockinger der zu seiner seite hat
der vize präsidentin der
österreichischen und
offiziersgesellschaft ja vielen dank
mein kompliment auch an dieser stelle
noch einmal für die schafe gesellschaft
die jüngste sehr kräftige man hört von
euch vielen dank für euren wirklich
umsetzbaren beitrag und dir an meiner
seite darf ich begrüßen herrn fischer
und klaus erfahrener miliz magath im
grunde und repräsentiert heute und hier
die stolze und offiziersgesellschaft
österreich ja also ich darf ich kurz
persönlich vorstellen mein name ist viel
zu halten und richard klaus ich bin
beordert als militzer tat bei weniger
patron 0 1 hoch und deutschmeister und
ich bin stolz darauf sein 40 jähriges
dienstjubiläum feiern zu dürfen also
wirklich ein resultat wie man ihn sich
vielleicht nicht immer wünscht ein
partei und kommandant schmunzeln da
hinten aber einer der mit herz und seele
dabei ist und sich natürlich auch jetzt
im rahmen der organisation
österreichischen dorf dieses
gesellschaft und dem landesverband der
wiener und auf diese gesellschaft für
das bundesheer auch in seiner privaten
zeit sehr stark einsetzt ja wunderbar
das macht man primär hier in der privat
zeit da muss die familie mitspielt dann
muss auch der arbeitgeber mitspielen das
ist vielleicht oftmals eine
herausforderung aber ich denke es lohnt
sich denn dieser beitrag ist eine
wesentliche eben für die sicherheit in
österreich und für die stabilität
wie sie organisiert das österreichische
und offiziersgesellschaft und wo findet
man euch wenn man mal suchen werde also
grundsätzlich sind wir in
landesverbänden organisiert und der
dachverband eben die österreichische
offiziersgesellschaft lebt von den
landesverbänden das spiegelt auch wieder
den repräsentativen vorstand der eu nie
wieder das sind die landespräsidenten
darin vertreten finden kann man die eu
die auf einer homepage und die einzelnen
landesorganisationen selbst strukturiert
selbst arbeitet auf diversen foren wie
youtube auf facebook auf die talk auf
webseiten also alles was das soziale
medium hergibt findet man die
landesorganisationen was es auch ein
bisschen schwerer macht mitglied einer
ug zu werden denn die rekrutieren wir
nur aus den landesorganisationen also
man kann nicht direkt mitglied in der eu
zu werden sondern man ist mitglied einer
landesorganisation und die werden dann
zusammengefasst in der übung ganz
hervorragend vielen dank für die
aufklärung bei und hofft hier ist das
rückgrat unserer armee das ist ein
geflügeltes wort aber ich kann das auch
sagen im grunde genommen alles
kommentaren das ist wahr ohne euch geht
es nicht und wir sind sehr dankbar wie
sezierte selber was braucht er wie sie
aufgestellt wie geht es unseren
kameradinnen und kameraden der
unteroffiziere also grundsätzlich würde
ich mal sagen wir bräuchten einen
orthopäden wenn wir das rückgrat der
österreichischen armee sind dann haben
wir kreuzschmerzen einerseits auf der
personellen besetzung
andererseits natürlich auch auf der
finanziellen seite
wir haben heute schon gehört durch den
herrn generalmajor haben wir sicher dass
zum beispiel dem motto der für die miliz
maßgebend verantwortlich ist ein eher
unterdotiert arbeitsplatz ist der aber
die masse der arbeit bezogen auf dem
lied abfedern muss also in nicht
übungszeiten ist dass unser quasi tor
ins bundesheer in ein ich selber habe
leidliche aber auch lustige erfahrungen
mit meinem auto also ich bin schon immer
der benchmark der ist fehlen wenn ich
anderen verweise jetzt gibt es arbeit
das heißt für mich persönlich oder weil
ich im auftrage manage kommandanten
wünsche beschwerden anregungen
kurzmeldungen und dergleichen mehr beim
einfordere und auch verlage das heißt
wenn der unteroffizier wirklich das
rückgrat dame sein soll und dass wir
sehen wir uns auch dann brauchen wir
nicht nur jetzt eine aufwertung der
einzelnen jobs entsprechend der
tätigkeit schon dann natürlich auch die
förderung und die forderung seitens des
ministeriums heißt es der armee hier mit
aufgaben betraut zu werden die auch
einem ausbildungs status entsprechend
honoriert und auch gesehen werden
absolut vielen dank das kennen wir alle
unterstützen
der unteroffizier als gestandener
gruppen kommentaren zugs comandante auch
da geht es darum diese erfahrenen
kameraden und kameraden langfristig auch
als mitarbeiter behalten zu können wir
haben einen massiven mangel hier in den
funktionen der fach und offiziere hier
soll es eine initiative geben für einen
um schüler wie seht ihr das
österreichische offizier und
offiziersgesellschaft ja wir haben ja
heute schon gehört diese verschränkung
zwischen bundesheer und der wirtschaft
wenn die wirtschaft und der
facharbeitermangel leidet dann wird es
das österreichische bundesheer wohl auch
tun auch wir haben einen
facharbeitermangel auch wenn er bei uns
fachunterricht um schulungsmöglichkeiten
ja befürworten wir allemal weil ich kann
nicht sein dass ein 55-jähriger und
dürfe die immer noch im felde draußen
als gruppen kommen dann halb zu kommen
oder chips kommen stellvertreter seinen
dienst versieht das andere problem ist
natürlich auch die langfristige planung
dahingehend weil wir jetzt gerade
erleben geburtenstarken jahrgänge sich
in den ruhestand in die pension
verabschieden und darauf oder anwuchs
die anfütterung oder die ausbildung zum
fach und dürfen sie ja nicht etwas ist
wie ein hund sport den ich rüttler und
ziffer 1 herunter sondern auch hier eine
langjährige erfahrung eine mehr modulare
über lange jahre sich ziehen der
ausbildung von staaten ist und von nöten
ist und ja über nacht kann man träumen
aber man kann nicht davon drei mal dass
facharbeiter fach und offiziere am
nächsten tag fixfertig vorgestellt dass
wir so nicht funktionieren da hat man
vielleicht und ich kann es aus meinem
zivilen leben aus meinem berufsleben
auch berichten ein wenig den
dornröschenschlaf die schlafen man hat
gewartet bis jemand jemanden wachküsst
ich warte immer noch auf den fuß
ja danke für diese punktierte aussage
kameradschaft ist auch ein wesentlicher
triebfeder und ein treiber im grunde
genommen insbesondere von den
wehrpflichtigen des mitgliedstaates
hier eben auch in ihrer freizeit
aktivitäten zu setzen
und auch als unteroffizier ist es
manchmal auch schwierig im rahmen der
ausbildung hier den richtigen weg für
sich zu finden bietet sich hier ein eine
art mentoring an habt ihr
ansprechpartner wo man wo einem dann
geholfen werden kann grundsätzlich ja
also wenn es nicht der bobverband selber
macht sich selbst zug gehörte miliz das
bataillon dann gibt es in jeder
landesorganisation einen blitz
beauftragten der quasi das sprachrohr in
die landesorganisation hinein ist sich
dann dort dieser themen annehmen kann
und wenn es funktioniert und wenn die
arbeit getan wird natürlich dann die
anliegen der milizsoldaten der miliz
kameraden weiter an die entsprechenden
stellen weiterleiten kann sei es jetzt
eine ausbildungs kalender der auf der
burg oder auf der milk und manchen
seminare angeboten wird sei es dass es
einzelne veranstaltungen gibt schon
weiterbildung aber die sind eher da in
der verantwortung der einzelnen
bataillone gelegen und wenn wir nicht
vergessen dürfen und das ist immer
wieder auch ein thema auch in den in den
landesorganisationen sind unsere
weiblichen kameraden auch hier haben wir
mittlerweile unter offizieren die
supremes kritisiert gehören die
gefördert gehören die gefordert gehören
da scheitern wir meistens am harris
personalamt weil wir da die
sonderverträge eingehen müssen damit die
damen wieder zur truppe kommen dürfen
und auch können wollen habe ich aus
meiner letzten nachdem wann die
einsatzerfahrungen die sammelt wollen
tun sie allemal der weg zu uns ist ein
sehr steiniger absolut also da ist
sicher noch potenzial
hier zu heben ja wenn man euch
unterstützen möchte wie kann man hier an
euch heran treten wie kann man sich
bestmöglich sehr visieren und so button
naja da geht es ja ähnlich wie taschen
gesellschaft also mit geld kann man fast
alles regeln also die unterstützung
wobei wir dürfen wir uns nicht
beschweren das bmf mit dem budget
abteilung ist das eher
großzügig kann man nicht sagen aber es
reicht um einen gewissen etat zur
verfügung zu haben was wir auf jeden
fall brauchen und da bin ich mensch und
ein kämpfer auch hier in wien ist eine
werbefläche eine werbefläche seitens für
den stand des und offiziers aber auch
natürlich für die landesorganisation
weil wir festgestellt haben gerade im
bereich der miliz die unter office
gesellschaften bundesweit
nicht so bekannt sind wie wir sie gerne
hätten wenn es erst einmal geschafft im
miliz anzeiger in unserer miliz info
ag eine quasi einen standes bericht
abzugeben wer sind wir wo findet man uns
woran wohin kann man sich also irgendwie
schon eingeführt gesagt haben ran an die
landesorganisationen und solche
möglichkeiten brauchen wir noch ein paar
mehr natürlich auch immer abgestützt hat
das österreichische bundesheer auf die
präsenten verbände und natürlich auch
die milizverbände oder war vielen dank
wer interesse hat meldet sich bitte hier
bei der österreichischen
offiziersgesellschaft wir bedanken uns
an dieser stelle recht herzlich bei dir
pizza leiten und richard kraus und beim
[Applaus]
wir dürfen uns bitten herrn richard ihr
johannes kainzbauer und herren privateer
magister ihr recht
der brigadier absoluter sie sind
präsident der österreichischen
offiziersgesellschaft und vertreten hier
tausende von österreichischen offizieren
können sie sich vielleicht kurz selber
vorstellen und auch die
offiziersgesellschaft
also mein name ist programm ich bin auch
ein milizoffizier wenn im zivilberuf
unternehmensberater speaker und
buchautor und beim österreichischen
bundesheer im beraterstab des
generalstabschefs beordert und in der
ausbildung unserer kommandanten tätig
als führungsverhaltens trainer
dankeschön
jetzt zur österreichischen
offiziersgesellschaft ist es ähnlich
organisiert wie wir jetzt gehört haben
die unter offiziersgesellschaft auf
länderebene races peter
offiziersgesellschaft anders es ist ganz
ähnlich da hat sich offensichtlich die
und offiziersgesellschaft ein vorbild an
uns genommen die offiziersgesellschaft
wurde im jänner 1960 gegründet als dach
von neuen landes offiziers
gesellschaften die analogie ist so wie
bei den unter offizieren mitglied kann
der einzelne bei einer
landesgesellschaft werden und die sind
dann gemeinsam in der österreichischen
gesellschaft vertreten jeweils durch
ihre präsidenten und die aufgabe der
österreichischen offiziersgesellschaft
ist jene themen in der öffentlichkeit zu
vertreten
die sodann im konsens aller
landesgesellschaften für von
bundesweiter bedeutung erachtet werden
und insofern bin ich als präsident der
österreichischen gesellschaft und der
botschaft und der sprachrohr für die
gemeinsamen anliegen jetzt kennen sie
wahrscheinlich viele aus den medien
speziell in den letzten wochen und
monaten
kommt man ja fast nicht mehr an ihnen
vorbei einen ihnen in den
verschiedensten medien vor welchen
herausforderungen steht das
österreichische offizierskorps
nun das österreichische offizierskorps
ist ein teil des österreichischen
bundesheers und wir stehen daher vor
exakt denselben
herausforderungen und weil sie die
medienarbeit angesprochen haben
gemeinsam mit den kameraden die heute
hier auch am podium sind haben wir schon
vor beginn dieser veranstaltung um 9 uhr
eine pressekonferenz gegeben die ersten
meldungen gehen bereits on air und haben
gerade auch dieses thema der
verpflichtenden gruppenübungen wieder
ganz besonders in den vordergrund
gestellt und wir unterstützen da das
ressort den miliz beauftragten und damit
sollen die wehrhaftigkeit österreichs
indem wir diese sehr berechtigte
forderung in die öffentlichkeit
transportieren und via medien sondern
auch an diesem politischen
entscheidungsprozess mitwirken er ist
ein extrem wichtiges thema das sie
angesprochen haben und das ist heute
schon mehrere male gehört haben das sind
die verpflichtenden milizübungen die er
seit knapp 20 jahren ausgesetzt sind sie
fordern die wiedereinführung war es gibt
es doch für forderungen der historischen
offiziersgesellschaft abgesehen von der
wiedereinführung der verpflichtung
regierungen und der das motor unter dem
wir arbeiten lautet wir sind das
sicherheitspolitische gewissen der
republik und so war es auch aus diesem
selbstverständnis heraus in den letzten
jahren vor allem unsere aufgabe darauf
hinzuweisen dass die wie sie sagen ein
bisschen naiv einschätzung der
sicherheitslage in europa und auf der
welt nicht nachhaltig ist und jetzt muss
man leider sagen als wir wollten es
nicht aber es ist leider so dass wird
durch diese
kriegerischen situationen in der ukraine
aber auch in anderen bereichen der welt
in dieser in dieser mit diesen warnungen
bestätigt wurden und daher sehen wir es
als notwendig nicht nur personell
sondern vor allem auch materiell dem
bundesheer wieder jene ressourcen zur
verfügung zu stellen die notwendig sind
den auftrag zu erfüllen ich arbeite
beispielsweise bei der pressekonferenz
darauf hingewiesen dass die 55.000
soldaten unseres unserer
mobilmachungsstärke
im ernst happel stadion platz finden ja
also man kann gar nicht sagen dass wir
ein riesengroßes her sind es ist eine
überschaubare anzahl aber was wirklich
bedenklich ist dass von diesen 55.000
nur ein teil ab justiert und ausgerüstet
ist das heißt die bevölkerung
österreichs
legt ihr vertrauen in ihre sicherheits
vertrauen in die hand von ganz ganz
wenigen und daher ist auch unser geld
das eigentlich auch als bevölkerung ins
bewusstsein zu nehmen und uns auch bei
dieser tätigkeit zu unterstützen
auch beim entscheidungsprozess auf dem
politischen parkett ja die materielle
einsatzbereitschaft ist wichtig sie
haben es angesprochen hat erst happel
stadion selbst dort kann es passieren
dass die 80 gerät brauchen und auch grad
antreten dort auf das ist eine
gefährliche umgebung aber kommen wir
vielleicht zurück zur personellen
der studenten einsatzbereitschaft es ist
ja eine langjährige forderung auch dass
der der begriff der zehnjährige
freiwilligen also die ef ausbildung
wieder zurückkomme soll beziehungsweise
haben dass wenige verstanden warum dies
ist dieser etablierte begriff diese
etablierte marke überhaupt abgeschafft
worden ist und durch den begriff kader
anwärter ausbildung ersetzt wurde man
hört jetzt
munkeln dass der begriff wieder
zurückkommen sollen begrüßen sie das ja
absolut ich begrüße das zutiefst
auch wir waren damals der meinung es ist
eine starke marke mit marken muss man
sorgfältig umgehen wir hätten es gerne
gehabt sie beizubehalten
natürlich muss man verstehen die karte
anwärter ausbildung ist aus dem
blickwinkel eines eklatanten mangels bei
den und offizieren entwickelt worden wo
man gesagt hat durch die zusammenlegung
der offiziers und und
offiziersausbildung kann man so dass
eine synergetische effekte nutzen
und das kommt dann sozusagen vor allem
den unter offizieren zu gute da da
stehen wir auch dazu denn als offizier
weiß man dass es ohne die unteroffiziere
die dann die schnittstelle zur
mannschaft darstellen nicht funktioniert
trotz alledem glaube ich ist es schon
auch wichtig auch der der zahl der
offiziere entspreche das augenmerk zu
geben wir haben im bereich der
berufsoffizier jetzt jahre hinter uns wo
20 oder 30 personen im jahr ausgemustert
wurden und stellen jetzt mit
überraschung fest dass uns die
berufsoffiziere fällen dass die miliz
offiziere fällen das wissen wir seit
geraumer zeit ja also man muss da schon
auch etwas
was diese quantitäten betrifft wieder
neu denken
quantität haben wir gehört wie sieht es
mit der qualität aus sind sie zufrieden
mit ihrem ausbildungsangebot spezielle
theresianischen militärakademie auf der
landesverteidigungsakademie und auch an
die schulen die für
milizoffizier oder angehende mediziner
angeboten werden nun wir freuen uns auch
dass wir seit dem jahr 2020 das war
unser 60
60 jähriges jubiläum da haben wir eine
partnerschaft mit der theresianischen
militärakademie
begründet über die wir uns sehr freuen
und auch eng zusammenarbeiten und da
kann man schon nach unserem partner
loben denn ich glaube die berufs
offiziersausbildung ist eine die nicht
nur schon seit 17 52 sehr sehr lange
währt sondern die sich auch im
internationalen vergleich absolut messen
kann und auch die
miliz offiziers aus und vor allem auch
weiter und fortbildung ist also auf
einem hervorragenden niveau sie wurde
immer wieder auch angepasst diese
einheits kommandanten
stabs ausbildung immer wieder auch neu
strukturiert aber immer auch unter
einbeziehung der expertise unter
erfahrungen
der offiziersgesellschaft aber auch der
betroffenen milizoffizier und so ist es
auch gelungen sondern den
diese curricula so zu gestalten dass es
dem einzelnen milizoffizier auch
einfacher ist an diesen fortbildungen
teilzunehmen und so gesehen so wird
recht zufrieden ja für einen herzlichen
dank für die einblicke es ist ohnehin
der trend in den letzten jahren dass die
miliz viel viel mehr eingebunden wird in
entscheidungen auf eine zentrale stelle
aber auch auf entscheidungen bei der
ausbildung um hier den bedürfnissen der
bedarfsträger rechnung zu tragen herr
präsident ich sage vielen herzlichen
dank dass sie heute gekommen sind und
ihre blicke gegeben haben betreffend die
österreichische offiziersgesellschaft
biete hier noch stehen bleiben und nicht
auf das wort übergeben einmal stockinger
der als gast hat den präsidenten des
miliz cabannes österreich bringe die ja
drk
vielen dank für die elegante überleitung
auch von unserer seite haben ein
herzliches dankeschön für die jahrelange
treue und unterstützung insbesondere
durch dich erich vielen dank dafür da
gehört viel mut aber eben auch ein
familiäres umfeld dazu und auch ein
berufliches umfeld wo man diese
ressourcen die oft in den samstag auf
den sonntag oft in die nacht hinein
gehen wir für dieses große ziel nämlich
die personelle und materielle
einsatzbereitschaft in vielen dank an
dieser stelle ja wir kommen aus dem
danke sagen heute gar nicht raus neben
mir herr dr kainzbauer präsident der
österreichischen des österreichischen
verbandes
herr präsident sie haben diese woche
eine hohe auszeichnung empfangen und
zwar vom landeshauptmann aus
oberösterreich
januar ist der schweizer er hat sie
ausgezeichnet für ihre verdienste mit
dem lampes
verdienstmedaille
besten dank für die gratulation nach ich
möchte die gelegenheit nutzen mich für
diese veranstaltung zu bedanken es ist
eine ganz tolle sache dass miliz die
möglichkeit gibt sich zu präsentieren
und ein feiertag abzuhalten also besten
dank für die leute die es ermöglicht
haben generali die das durchführen
herzlichen dank und da war vielen dank
ja der österreichische milizverband ist
auch medial immer wieder sehr
konstruktiv aus unserer sicht hier
aufgefallen das gefällt uns sehr gut wir
sind menschen die aus der wirtschaft
kommen wir wissen ganz genau der ton
macht die musik und es ist oftmals
einfach wichtig dass man testet was bei
der empfängerin beim empfänger ankommt
und weniger auf sich selbst konzentriert
was man eigentlich hier im grunde
genommen auch seine das sind sehr
verbindliche und konstruktiver
beispiele die sie erbringen unter dem
motto ich hoffe wir deutschen uns nicht
wer will findet wege
so hieß es ich habe 46 jahre dienstjahre
im bundesheer habe also hoch und tief
der miliz erlebt ich habe einen
milizverband kennengelernt war jahrelang
mitglied wird die vier hauptamtliche
mitarbeiter m/w kommandos sitzen gehabt
hat mit einer regelmäßig
vierteljährlichen zeitung ich habe den
niedergang der
militärischen und hat wie man nicht
sondern am feiertag ich sehe licht am
horizont das was ich aus der
generalmajor haben es ja schon gesagt
hat es tut sich was es bewegt sich was
grund warum es der milizverband
neu hat man mir gerade vorgestern wieder
gesagt gibt es gibt es sehr viele
milizverbände aber keiner der wirklich
konstruktiv und weiterentwicklung der
militär arbeitet hat und das war der
grund warum uns auch 20 90 entschlossen
haben diesen milizverband österreich neu
zu gründen und unser anliegen ist es
dass wir konstruktiv bei der
weiterentwicklung der miliz mitarbeiten
vielen dank so ist es auch für uns
aufgefallen positiv auffällig gewesen
vielleicht können sie das noch einmal
auch hinterleuchten das netzwerk des
österreichischen miliz verbandes
insbesondere auch ein großer
unterstützer und förderer general ham se
dar
ich habe meiner miliz karriere sehr viel
mit planungen entwickelter miliz zu tun
gehabt ich war
evaluierungsbericht bund ist jahr 2010
ist vertreter der marita jungs konnten
ich war dann beim projekt neuausrichtung
der miliz dabei wo er bereits mit büro
des miliz beauftragten serien
zusammengearbeitet haben der
milizverband ist jetzt auch bei dem
arbeitspaket 02 mit sehr vielen unserer
mitglieder dabei und arbeitet
konstruktiv mit
ich bin im beraterstab des
generalstabschef und und kümmerlich dort
eben und die miliz in meiner
arbeit sind natürlich sehr viele
forderungen oder ideen aufgestellt die
einige schon in erfüllung gegangen sind
eine ist zum beispiel auch dieser
satellit und unterstützt wurden wir
immer hervorragend durch das büro des
mitglieds beauftragten und mit
generalmajor hans eder ist nicht nur der
miliz und ich glaube dem ganzen
bundesheer ein glücksgriff gelungen das
als türöffner
es normal bürger eigentlich nicht auch
dankeschön an den medienbeauftragten ja
und weil wir heute bei uns haben auch
zwei kameraden die hier jahrelang sehr
teuer für die miliz verbunden hier
arbeiten zum einen herrn oberst
guggenberger der heute bei uns ist und
zum anderen oberster selten hammer die
hier ganz aller bonner das büro des
minsker auftraten managen und hier auch
wirklich echtes hintergrund ein tolles
netzwerk auch generieren komme auf den
kernpunkt wir roma thema einfach in der
wirtschaft wenn es um die akzeptanz geht
wenn es um die wertschätzung für diese
tätigkeiten geht da wurden tolle
programme ausgearbeitet zum beispiel die
initiative zierung vielleicht könnten
sie dazu noch etwas sagen
mit general johannes eder heute schon
gesagt ein erster schritt ist getan
und der eindruck der nicht bekommen wenn
ich mit vielen meiner kameraden spreche
ist dass die akzeptanz der miliz auf
oberster ebene in der wirtschaft
eigentlich da ist das sind
möglicherweise leute da der selber
früher noch in der miliz mitgewirkt
haben aber dann beim direkten
vorgesetzten bei match ahmann gibt es
dann
restaurantkette miliz nicht
arbeitnehmer ist dann eine woche weg
ich hatte das glück 20 jahren einen
internationalen konzern zu arbeiten wie
ich gesagt habe ich muss jetzt zur
drucklegung war die personalabteilung
tag sagt er umschreibt man was dass ich
nicht gehen muss meint direkt der chefin
amerikaner hat gesagt super g zum
mediator lernt man was das kennen wir
ebenfalls in unternehmen nutzen es war
ein skandinavischer konzern also da wo
er eine miliz tätigkeit nie ein
hinderungsgrund
wir sprechen hier aber auch immer über
die wirtschaft es gibt aber auch einen
zweiten kosten arbeitgeber in österreich
das ist der öffentliche dienst der wird
bei dieser diskussion immer ausgelassen
und meine erfahrung ist dass es dort
mittlerweile größere schwierigkeiten für
die akzeptanz der miliz gibt bei den bei
der wirtschaft und hier ist ein nächster
schritt wo wir vom milizverband daran
setzen werden um die situation zu
verbessern absolut es geht hier um das
sichtbarmachen unserer qualifikation wir
haben ja auch eine neue botschaft
installiert nämlich der miliz soldat als
qualifizierter mitarbeiter das muss man
sich einmal vorstellen wenn man den
dienstgrad den ich trage nämlich major
dann hat man da viele jahre erfahrung
heißt auf mehreren akademien gewesen
wenn man diese führungsausbildung
privatwirtschaftlich bezahlen müsste
dann wäre das im bereich von rund 30 bis
35 tausend euro wenn man einen dienst
gerade in der kategorie
bataillonskommandant oberst aufwärts
dann ist das eine führungsausbildung die
mit sicherheit 50.000 euro und aufwärts
hier zu betrachten ist das wird gemacht
parallel zum beruf parallel zum familie
und zum privatleben und das gehört
natürlich sichtbar gemacht und das ist
aus unserer sicht ja auch wirklich ein
sofort ersichtlich nutzen in der
privatwirtschaft ist diese tüv
zertifizierung war vorgestern wieder
dabei wird diese zertifikate verliehen
wurden das ist eine ganz tolle sache das
bundesheer hat er mit sowas begonnen ich
glaube das hat kompetenz
zertifikat oder sowas geheißen und meine
kadic wie immer das ist zwar für das
bundesheer schön aber wenn diese in
zivile arbeitgeber der links mit militär
zum tun dort liest versteht das nicht
das militär muss mit zivilisten zivil
reden und das ist jetzt mit dem tüv
zertifikat gelungen wenn dort ein
zivilist das sieht dann weiß er welche
kompetenzen der bundeswehr erworben hat
und wie man die zivilen beruf einsetzen
kann oder war vielen dank vielleicht
dürfen wir noch nachfragen wenn man sich
für den österreicher milizverband
interessiert wie kann man bei euch
mitglied werden und wie kann man euch
bestmöglich unterstützen so wie bei
allen anderen vereinen wir haben eine
homepage moritz verband.de wir sind auf
facebook wir sind auch auf linkedin das
ist ganz wichtig für uns dass wir dort
auch auf
zivile ebene berufliches netzwerk bilden
unterstützen kann man uns kein thema
mitglied wird es gibt drei arten von
mitgliedschaften kurz ordentliches
mitglied seit 20 euro aus also
unterstützendes mitglied zahlt fünf euro
und außerordentliches mitglied zahlt
praktisch gar nichts aber es wird
beteilt mit unserer information wird
kein stimmrecht und bei einer
generalversammlung aber das ist egal
also möglichkeiten gibt es genug braucht
nur im internet nachschauen oder jung
dem anrufenden konnten das zugeschickt
und dabei präsident vielen dank dass sie
heute bei uns waren danke auch für das
sichtbarmachen der leistung das sind die
hidden heroes in wirklichkeit die
interessensvertretungen ich denke diese
applaus gehört jetzt noch einmal unseren
interessensvertretungen der
zielgesellschaft der und
offiziersgesellschaft der
offiziersgesellschaft und auch das mit
des verbandes österreich
ja wir sind am ende unserer heutigen
sendung angelangt wir haben versucht das
sehr kurzweilig zu
gestalten auch mit einem entsprechenden
fachinformationen die wertigkeit im
detail musste sichergestellt werden dass
wir uns wichtig wir haben viele
kameradinnen und kameraden hier auch
gezeigt und sagen an dieser stelle danke
schön ohne diese herrschaften wäre es
nicht gegangen sie sind jetzt nicht
sichtbar aber es sind die kameradinnen
und kameraden der heeres bild und film
stelle vielen dank für die gute
zusammenarbeit wir haben letztes jahr
den ersten probe des polen gehabt und
das was wir heute gezeigt haben weil es
noch einmal ein richtiger schock ja und
wir sagen natürlich auch dankeschön an
unsere
vortragenden genauer als bitte an alle
vortragenden alle die sonst hat er
mitgewirkt haben vielen vielen
herzlichen dank
sie haben wesentlich dazu beigetragen
dass das heute eine tolle veranstaltung
geworden ist ja wir sind jetzt am ende
angelangt und der slogan der uns im
grunde genommen hier wirklich antreibt
ist wer will findet wege denn wer nicht
will findet ein anderer gründe und
außerdem warum es nicht geht das ist für
uns zu langweilig und so zählen und wir
schaffen das gemeinsam weil wir sind
eine sehr
[Applaus]
mein name ist oberst bernhard studio ich
bin der kommandant vom jägerbataillon
wien 2 unsere heutige
truppenübungsplatz bruckneudorf
im burgenland statt neuer drei
schwerpunkte einerseits fortsetzen der
schießausbildung
sturmgewehr 77 und pistole 80 der zweite
punkt ist gefechts dienst zum thema
kontrolle von personen und kfz im
gelände und entlang von strassen und
drittens trainieren wir das durchsuchen
von gelände abschnitten das dient
einerseits umstellen bewaffnete personen
kann aber auch angewendet werden wenn es
dem auffinden vermisster personen in
zusammenarbeit mit behörden dient
1 nicht aus
[Musik]
kompanie
dies ist meine letzte truppenübung als
kommandant dieses herausstehenden
verbandes und werde am ende dieser übung
das kommando nachfolger übergeben
getreu unserem motto stets bereit sind
wir fit für die zukunft
es bedarf aber weiteren intensiven
trainings unser niveau zu halten dazu
wünsche ich dem verband alles alles gute
für die zukunft
[Musik]
[Applaus]